THIRD HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE.
TODAY WE HAVE TWENTY TWO BILLS
ON THE AGENDA WITH SEVEN BILLS
ON CONSENT.
PLEASE NOTE THE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB THREE SIX SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA AND ITEM
NUMBER EIGHTEEN AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS.
HAVE BEEN PULLED FROM THE AGENDA
SO WE WILL BE HEARING A TOTAL OF
TWENTY BILLS TODAY.
AS A REMINDER WE LIMIT TESTIMONY
TO TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EACH WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES MAY ADD
ON BY STATING THEIR NAME AND
AFFILIATION. FOR TODAY'S HEARING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THREE OF US WILL
BE SUBSTITUTING FOR DOCTOR
JOAQUIN ARAMBULA ON OUR
COMMITTEE.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REVERSE.
WHEN SHE ARRIVES FOR BEING PART
OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY -- WHERE
DO WE BEGIN AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
DOCTOR CHOI?
THERE ARE ALL RIGHT.
WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE
I SEE THIS.
WELL IF MR COOLEY SAID YOU CAN
GO AHEAD THEN YOU WILL GO AHEAD.
A LET'S HERE.
ON ITEM NUMBER.
FOURTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY FIVE BY SURE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHARON QUIRK SILVA.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER.
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE TO
YOU. TO TALK ABOUT A BILL THAT
IS NOT ONLY.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THROUGH OUR
OUR STATE TO TALK ABOUT BUT ALSO
PERSONALLY IMPORTANT TO ME -- IT
IS NO SECRET THAT TOUGH NOT ONLY
OUR STATE BUT OTHERS ARE FACING
A SEVERE HOMELESSNESS CRISIS WE
ALSO KNOW WITHIN THAT HOMELESS
POPULATION THAT WE HAVE.
MANY ON OUR STREETS THAT ARE NOT
ONLY HOPE HOMELESS BUT ALSO
EXPERIENCE SOME TYPE OF MENTAL
HEALTH -- ISSUE.
AS WE HAVE FOCUSED IN OUR STATE
OF HAVING HOMELESSNESS.
BE A PRIORITY WE SEE MANY MANY
BILLS COMING OUT.
THAT ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS
ACCORDING TO THE PRELIMINARY
POINT IN TYING COUNT.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE E..
THAN NUMBER IS OVER SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE CURRENTLY IN ORANGE
COUNTY.
WHAT'S EVEN MORE DRAMATIC THAN
THE SIX THOUSAND IS THAT WE'VE
HAD OVER THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE
DIE ON THE STREETS OF ORANGE
COUNTY AND IN JUST MARCH. THIRTY
THIRTY PEOPLE DYING ON THE
STREETS OF ORANGE COUNTY.
THAT SOME PEOPLE FROM OTHER CUT
COUNTRIES LOOK AT ORANGE COUNTY
IN THE ORANGE COUNTY HOUSE
WIFE'S IN OUR REALITY TV SHOWS.
AND THINK OUR STREETS ARE PAVED
WITH GOLD.
AND YET WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE ARE
DYING.
AND AND ALLEYS IN OUR HOSPITALS.
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE ARE DYING.
BECAUSE OF ADDICTION ISSUES AND
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE ARE DYING
ON OUR FREEWAY SIDELINES AND IF
THEY'RE NOT DYING THEY'RE LIVING
THERE [inaudible]
I TO SUFFERED A LOSS THIS FALL
WITH MY BROTHER BILLY J. SO.
BILLY IS THE SECOND YOUNGEST OUT
OF MY FOUR BROTHERS AND HE DIED
THIS FALL.
OF BY BEING HIT BY A CAR.
ABOUT. TWO TO THREE BLOCKS AWAY
FROM WHERE HE WAS STAYING.
HE SUFFERED FOR MANY YEARS WITH
ADDICTION.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HOMELESSNESS
HE HAD A HOME AND A FAMILY WHO
CARED FOR HIM INCLUDING MY
EIGHTY TWO YEAR OLD MOTHER WHO
SPENT MANY NIGHTS LOOKING FOR
HIM?
WE SPENT MANY TIMES WITH OUR
LARGE FAMILY HOUSING HIM AND YET
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THEY DON'T ALWAYS.
STAY ON A PROGRAM AND THESE
PROGRAMS ARE NOT NINETY DAY
PROGRAMS AND THEY'RE NOT SIXTY
DAY PROGRAM SOMETIMES THEY TAKE
MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
SO MY AB TWELVE NINETY FIVE AND
I APPRECIATE SO MUCH NORMALLY
THE CHAIRS COMMITMENT BUT ALSO
THE CONSULTANTS WORK -- AS I
WANTED.
SOLUTION AND FELT THAT WE HAD
ONE WITH FAIR VIEW OF THE
STATE'S LAND OF A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN ACRES AN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND THAT WE COULD ALONG WITH A
HERO IT JUDGE CARTER -- WHO HAS
SAID THAT WE WILL NOT TOLERATE
THIS AN ORANGE COUNTY OR ANY
STATE A CITY?
THAT WE COULD HOUSE THEM
URGENTLY WE NOW KNOW THAT THAT'S
NOT POSSIBLE BECAUSE MANY OF THE
COMMITMENTS THROUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- AND ALSO -- THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT.
NEEDS TO BE TAKE TO PLAN THIS
CAREFULLY BUT AB TWELVE NINETY
FIVE WILL ASSIST UP TO TWO
HUNDRED OF THE MOST SEVERELY
MENTALLY ILL AND CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS BY ALLOWING
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP.
A TEMPORARY MENTAL HEALTH
PROGRAM AT THE FAIR VIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER A STATE
OWNED FACILITY ONCE IT SEIZES
AND PLEASE HEAR ME ON THAT
SEIZES. TO OPERATE AS A DEVOUT
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER ITH ME
TODAY WE HAVE REBEKAH GONZALEZ
BUT BEFORE I AND MY COMMENTS.
I DO WANT TO TO NOTE THAT.
I'VE HAD MANY PEOPLE TALK TO ME
ABOUT THIS AND WHEN.
THE PASSAGE OF THAT I WROTE
ABOUT MY BROTHER WAS.
PUT OUT I HAD HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE
TEXAN ME THAT THEY PERSONALLY
ARE SUFFERING THESE TYPE OF
THINGS.
AND I EVEN HAD SOMEBODY RECENTLY
ON MY FACEBOOK SAID WELL WHY
DIDN'T YOU HOUSE THEM.
AND WHY DIDN'T YOU TAKE CARE OF
YOUR FAMILY AND THE TRUTH IS WE
ALL DID WHAT WE COULD AND TRIED
FOR SO MANY YEARS AS MANY
FAMILIES DUE TO DO SO TO ASSUME
THAT FAMILIES DON'T WANT TO CARE.
TAKE CARE OF THEIR LOVED ONES IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT TRUE.
BUT WEEK COME TO A POINT IN OUR
CAREERS WE HAVE TO MAKE BOLD
DECISIONS AND WE HAVE TO MAKE
BRAVE DECISIONS AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE DECISIONS UP.
THAT OTHERS MAY NOT LIKE OR
AGREE WITH AND THIS IS A TIME IN
MY TIME OF SERVING THAT THAT I
DO NOT WANT TO NEGOTIATE.
I DO NOT WANT TO WAIT ANY LONGER
AS WE SEE PEOPLE DYING SO THANK
YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND WE
HAVE REBEKAH GONZALEZ HERE.
HELLO REBECCA GONZALEZ AND I
REPRESENT THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY TEN THOUSAND
PROFESSIONAL SOCIAL WORK.
WORKERS IN THE STATE I'M WITH
THE DEGREE FROM AN ACCREDITED
SOCIAL WORK PROGRAM.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL AS
IT WILL HELP THOSE EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCING A MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS AND CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS
AN ORANGE COUNTY.
SOCIAL WORKERS ARE THE LARGEST
PROVIDER AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND IN THE NATION AND
WE HAVE SEEN THE CRISIS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THEIR HOMELESS
POPULATION. FOR EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL ILLNESS.
ACORDING TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN DEVELOPMENT
THERE ARE AN ESTIMATED FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS ACROSS OUR
NATION.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME 222% OF ALL
HOMELESS PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WHICH IS THE LARGEST SIZE SURE
BY STATE. 39% OF THE NATION'S
CHRONIC HOMELESS POPULATION
WHICH IS DEFINED AS THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE LIVED ON
THE STREETS FOR OVER A YEAR OR
AND ARE SUFFERING FROM.
MENTAL ILLNESS RESIDE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL DIRECT
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A PLAN
FOR A TEMPORARY SHELTER UPON
CLOSURE AT THE FAIR VIEW OF
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER TO CARE FOR
THOSE IN CRISIS.
MANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
EXHIBIT COMPLEX AND LONG TERM
HEALTH CONDITIONS INCLUDING
MENTAL ILLNESS SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS PHYSICAL DISABILITIES
OR OTHER MEDICAL CONDITIONS ONCE
CLOSED THE FAIRVIEW
DEVELOPMENTAL CENTER ISN'T
AVAILABLE TEMPORARY.
LOCATION FOR THESE SERVICES AND
COULD BE RE USE FOR THIS THESE
PURPOSES. FIVE THEREFORE WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B..
TWELVE NINETY FIVE THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THEIR PARENTS SOME WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA AND
REGRETFULLY WERE IN OPPOSITION
RIGHT NOW -- BUT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH AUTHOR ON
THIS ISSUE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
MEMBERS QUESTIONS COMMENTS
[inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU CHAIR RON THANK A
MEMBER OF WORK SAID OF OUR ABOUT
YOUR CONCERN.
ON THE HOME THIS POPULATION AND
THEN ALSO WHAT PARTICULARLY
MENTALLY ILL.
A ITALIA AGREED TO USE.
OUR OF PRESSING ISSUES -- IN OUR
STATE AND THEN ALSO IN OUR
ORANGE COUNTY AREA I OR SO COME
FROM.
YOU ARE -- ADDRESSING -- CORRECT
ISSUES.
WHEN THE QUESTION THAT I HAVE IS
THAT -- NOT NECESSARILY OPPOSING.
ON TO A RIGHT THE MEASURES THAT
WE NEED TO COME UP WITH A BUT
THIS BUT THE KILLER NOW FACILITY
AT THE FEAR VIEW.
HAS BEEN VERY -- A HOTLY DEBATED
TELL WHAT IT SHOULD BECOME --
Và.
ARE AFTER -- INTELLECTUALLY.
ARE.
DEVELOP DEVELOPMENTALLY
CHALLENGED THE POPULATION -- IN
WEST THERE AND THEY'RE STILL OUT
THERE WHEN THE VAN TO FACILITIES
A CLOSE THE WHAT -- HOW THAT THE
PUTS FACILITY WOULD BE YOU STOP --
BUT THE A WINDOW WITH THE THIS
IS THE RIGHT APPROACH.
THAT THE WE AT THE STATE LEVEL
[inaudible]
OUR TWO HELLO.
ARE IN THE DESK IN A THE HOW THE
BUILDING SHOULD BE USED.
TO FOR WHEN.
THERE IS -- A DIRECT
[inaudible]
OUR COMMUNITY.
A STATE.
SUCH AS STE THE CITY OF COSTA
MESA IS -- A VERY MUCH
INTERESTED IN.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY ALSO
BOARDED THE RECENTLY CAST THAT
IDEA -- AND THEN ALSO.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER YOU HAVE
WORKED WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FROM THAT DISTRICT.
AND WHO SHOULD HAVE A MORE
INTERESTED JEAN INTEREST TO IT
ON DISAPPOINTED A TOPIC.
SO IF YOU CAN EXPLAIN.
Y. E. O. IDEA.
I MEAN WHICH IS NORMAL --
HOWEVER.
CIRCUMVENTING THE LOCAL --
DECISION AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO NAY TO WORK OUT.
IN ALL WHATEVER THE BEST USE
WHATEVER DECISION THEY WILL IT
IT IT IT IS A MADE TO ORDER DEAL
FOR THE COULD CALL.
I HAVE NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT
THE INTERNAL SO WHAT KIND OF A
COORDINATION YOU HAVE DONE WITH --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KADI -- NO
WORRIES.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR.
THEY DIDN'T HER INVOLVEMENT IN
THIS PROCESS.
BUT YES I OF A NEW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUDDY PETRIE-NORRIS THE
CAMPUS IS HOSTED AND COSTA MESA
IT IS A STATE PROPERTY AND AS WE
LOOK AT THESE MAJOR ISSUES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
LOOKING REGIONALLY ON I SOLVING
ISSUES IS IMPERATIVE AS THIS
LAND WAS FORMALLY AND CURRENTLY
USED AS A DISABLED HOSPITAL AND
THERE WILL BE A CLOSURE AND A
AREA TO LOOK AT THE FUTURE OF
THAT WHICH CAN ACTUALLY BE DONE.
AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE LOOKING
FOR A TEMPORARY SITE.
IN ADDITION TO THAT CAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATRICK.
UP WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS UP REGARDING THE
SHE HAS A BILL.
RELATED TO SURPLUS PROPERTY
THERE'S OTHERS THAT ARE
INTERESTED SO THESE WILL TAKE
MANY CONVERSATIONS I'M COMMITTED.
TO CONTINUING OUR CONVERSATIONS
I'M CONTENT.
MINTED TO ALSO LOOKING FOR OTHER
LOCATIONS THE URGENCY IS NOW --
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS A TEMPORARY
PLAN BUT ORANGE COUNTY IN EVERY
OTHER COUNTY AND THE STATE TO
KILL CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO PUT
THIS ON THEIR HIGH PRIORITY LIST
NEEDS TO TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE DOING EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
KEEP PEOPLE FROM DYING ON OUR
STREET WHETHER IT'S JUST THE
HOMELESS IN IT'S A SCENARIO
WHERE SOMEONE IS SICK OR WHETHER
THEY'RE SICK AND THEY HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH.
ISSUES SO THAT THIS IS NOT --
AGAINST -- THE MEMBER THAT
REPRESENTS THAT AREA.
IT HAPPENS TO BE IN HER --
COMMUNITY BUT STATE OWNED LAND --
THAT IS INCREDIBLY VALUABLE TO
OUR COUNTY IS CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
DISCUSS BUT ANY MY COMMENTS -- I
IS A SAID I AM A COMMITTED TO
FINDING A SOLUTION AND I KNOW
THAT THE SUDDENLY MEMBER
ASSEMBLY WOMAN FROM -- SOUTH
COUNTY IS AS WELL SO WE ARE NOT
ONLY SPEAK ALMOST REGULARLY
ABOUT THIS BUT WE ARE PLANNING
ON EVEN MEETING THIS WEEKEND
ABOUT IT.
SO BUT JUST ENDING THERE IS NO
OTHER.
ISSUE THAT I THINK RISES TO THE
OCCASION THAT WE NEED TO AGREE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT EDUCATION
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION WHEN WETALK
ABOUT HEALTHCARE IF PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE A PLACE TO LIVE.
AND THERE IS NO ONE THAT THEY
CAN TURN TO THEY ARE ENDING UP
IN OUR HOSPITALS THEY ARE ENDING
UP IN OUR JAILS OR ARE PARKS AND
THIS COSTS OUR STATE AND NORMA'S
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
AND THE TRUTH IS THAT ALL OF
THOSE OTHER THINGS THAT WE WANT
TO INVEST IN IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE DIMINISHED IF
SOMEBODY DOES NOT HAVE A PLACE.
TO TO LIVE OFF HOME AND SO I
WILL CONTINUE WORKED WITH THIS
I'VE WORKED WITH THE GOVERNOR ON
THIS AND I ASKED NOT ONLY THE
GOVERNOR BUT MY COLLEAGUES TO TO
MAKE A STATEMENT.
THAT WE ARE TOO GOOD OF A COUNTY
AND A COUNTRY AND A STATE TO
ALLOW THIS RIGHT HERE ON OUR
CAPITAL WE SEE PEOPLE LIVING
HERE THAT WERE ON THE CAPITAL.
IN THIS VICINITY UP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO THAT HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH.
PROBLEMS AND OFTEN WE SEE PEOPLE
WALKING BY BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO.
AND YET WE DO.
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES BUT IT'S
ABOUT THE WILL SO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
YEAH AS A FOLLOW UP ON MY I WAS
NOT THE QUESTIONING ABOUT THE
URGENCY AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT THE HOME THIS MUST BE POOR
AND ALSO MENTALLY ILL POPULATION
AND THEY NEED TO FIND A BETTER.
FACILITY SO TO BE HOLLISTER AND
THE CARED FOR I'M ON THE RAISING
THE QUESTION WHETHER -- WE HAD
SOMEONE IS -- ALL OVER THE LOCAL --
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE COME UP WITH THE OF
CONSENSUS BUILDING BECAUSE SOME
AMONG MANY AYE DEERS AND THEN
ALSO -- THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF A
NOTORIOUS SO WHERE DOES SHE SAYS
SUPPORTING YOUR IDEAS.
BECAUSE AS WE AS A COULD YOU SEE
YOU ARE EMPHASIZING THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A STATE OWNED A
HOWEVER.
WE DO HAVE -- OUR JEWISH --
DISTRICT INTERESTED SO I THINK
THAT IT'D BE MORE IDEAS TO WORK
WITH THAT THE REPRESENT.
TATIAN OF THAT DISTRICT.
AGAIN I WILL REPEAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHOI A I HAVE BEEN IN
CLOSE COMMUNICATION I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT -- THE SUDDENLY
MEMBER AND I HAVE THE SAME
VISION OF WHAT OF FAIR VIEW CAN
BE AND WE CERTAINLY HAVE NOTED
THAT I ALSO BELIEVE THAT SHE AND
I CAN WORK AS CLOSELY AS
POSSIBLE TO COME TO A SOLUTION.
BUT AS FAR AS COURTESY FROM ONE
PERSON'S DISTRICT TO ANOTHER --
I CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS IS LOCATED IN -- DISTRICT
BUT I WILL AGAIN SAY AS
CAREFULLY AS I CAN THIS IS NOT
ABOUT COURTESY IT'S ABOUT
URGENCY IN IT'S ABOUT PEOPLE
DYING AND IT'S ABOUT.
US STANDING BY AND WATCHING THIS
AND AND AS COURTEOUS IT AS I CAN
BE TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE AND TO
MY COLLEAGUE IN THE SOUTH.
I'M GOING TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT
AND STAND UP FOR SOMETHING THAT
IS NOT OKAY WE CANNOT SEE PEOPLE
DIE IN ORDER STREETS.
IN AMERICA ANYWHERE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI THOSE ARE
VERY GOOD COMMENTS AND GOOD
QUESTIONS.
OF I I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALSO FOR BEING
CREATIVE THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
AND I THINK WE ALL NEED TO DEAL
WITH IT IN OUR OWN DISTRICTS BUT
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT IT
GOES BEYOND OUR LINES.
IT CANNOT JUST BE.
OUR LITTLE DISTRICT AND THE GOOD
THING AND I DO APPRECIATE THAT
YOU AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
PETRIE-NORRIS HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS AND I AM WELL
AWARE OF THAT -- BUT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS DR CHOI
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
VERY GOOD -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
SEC A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
FOR THE BILL THAT IS CALLED AB
TWELVE NINETY FIVE BUT I CALL IT
BILLY'S BILL.
WELL THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
SHARING VERY PERSONAL -- HISTORY
RELATED TO THIS I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON YOUR CHOICE OF
WITNESSES -- YOU HAVE SELECTED A
WITNESS WHO COMES FROM MY
HOMETOWN OF COLTON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING WITH US REBEKAH
GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU AND
WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM THEN WE
WILL -- GET.
GET THIS BILL MOVING.
VERY GOOD -- WE ARE TAKING A
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS --
ITEM NUMBER ONE I SEE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WICKS HAS ARRIVED.
AB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN HOW.
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN ENGLISH THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AND STAFF COMMITTEE STOCKS.
OF FOOD INSECURITY AMONG
HOUSEHOLDS WITH SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN REMAINS HIGH ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
FOOD IN SECURITIES ASSOCIATED
WITH NEGATIVE HEALTH
DEVELOPMENTAL AND EDUCATIONAL
OUTCOMES IN CHILDREN WHO GROW UP
IN FOOD SECURE HOUSEHOLDS OFTEN
FALL BEHIND COMPARED TO THEIR
FOOD SECURE APPEARS. TO REDUCE
CHILD HUNGER THE FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEALS PROGRAMS HAS
HELPED CHILDREN GAIN ACCESS TO
ADEQUATE FOOD AND IS AIMED TO
REDUCE FOOD IN SECURITY AND
PROMOTE HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT.
WE DO KNOW THAT THESE PROGRAMS
WORK MANY STUDENTS IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT SCHOOL
DISTRICT I REPRESENT -- HAVE
CHILDREN ON THESE PROGRAMS.
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF IT IN
SECURE CHILDREN ARE RECEIVING
FREE AND REDUCED MALES BUT THEY
ARE NOT RECEIVING BENEFITS
THROUGH CAL FRESH.
WE SEE INCONSISTENCIES IN THIS
REPORTS OF FOUND THAT
CALIFORNIA'S HAS LOWER
ENROLLMENT IN FREE REDUCE MEALS.
PROGRAMS WITH 51% OF ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM
AND ONLY 24% OF CHILDREN.
OF THOSE CHILDREN -- ENROLLED IN
CALIFORNIA.
HIGHER PARTICIPATION ACCESS TO
FOOD NUTRITION PROGRAMS SUCH AS
CAL FOR USHER WOULD HELP PRODUCE
FOOD AND SECURITY -- AND POVERTY --
FOR OUR CHILDREN'S Và AND
FAMILIES.
MY BILL AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WILL DIRECT STATE
DEPARTMENTS LOCAL HUMAN SERVICE
AGENCIES AND KEY STAKEHOLDERS TO
EXAMINE DATA AN ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT BENEFITS PROGRAMS IN
ORDER TO FIND THE BEST.
POSSIBLE SOLUTION AND DEVELOP A
STATEWIDE PROCESS THAT WOULD
IMPLEMENT.
AT THE XCELERATED ROMAN OF
CHILDREN INTO CAL FRESH IT'S
ABOUT ENSURING THAT CHILDREN GET
THE FOOD THAT THEY NEED.
BY EXAMINING THE INFORMATION
THAT WE HAVE FROM OUR DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS AND PROGRAMS WE CAN
CREATE A STREAMLINED PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA FAMILIES.
FACING FOOD AND SECURITY HAVE
EVERY AVAILABLE RESOURCES EVERY
AVAILABLE RESOURCE FOR WHICH
THEY ARE ELIGIBLE.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
CALIFORNIA WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
INTRODUCE OUR WITNESSES.
KATHY CENTER LING AND BECKY
GERSHON AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
KATHY SUNDERLAND WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
THIS IDEA WAS BROUGHT FORWARD BY
MULTIPLE COUNTIES DURING OUR
INTERNAL LEGISLATIVE PRIORITY
SETTING LAST YEAR AND I THINK IN
IN PART IT'S DRIVEN BY A BILL
THAT WE SPONSORED SEVERAL YEARS
AGO BY THEN ASSEMBLY WOMAN
SKINNER A BEFORE.
TWO IN WHICH SORT OF VOLUNTARY
DATA MATCH WITH STRUCTURE
BETWEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COUNTIES AND IT'S SIMPLY TOO
COMPLICATED IT'S NOT WORKING OUT
AS WELL AS WE HOPE IN THE HASN'T
REALLY PRODUCED THE NUMBERS THAT
WE EXPECTED.
WE KNOW THAT HUNGRY CHILDREN ARE
NOT PREPARED TO LEARN AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN WHO ARE ON
THE SCHOOL MUCH LUNCH PROGRAM.
BUT WHO ARE POTENTIALLY ELIGIBLE
BUT NOT A ROLE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
AND THERE HAVE JUST BEEN VARIOUS
EFFORTS SORT OF INFORMAL TO
PARSE OUT THE PROCESS HE'S
ACROSS THE PROGRAMS.
AND ALSO ACROSS THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM WHICH IS SORT OF THE
THIRD OP PROGRAM THAT THE BILL
NOW BRINGS SAID.
ON TO HAVE A REALLY PANNED OUT
EITHER BUT THEY'VE ALSO BEEN
INFORMAL THERE'S BARRIERS THAT
SORT OF THE USING THE DATA
ACROSS THE PROGRAMS -- THIS
ISN'T AN EASY NOT TO CRACK BUT
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE BEING
INVOLVED IN SAYING WE WANT YOU
TO GET IN A ROOM WE WANT FOLKS
TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO YOU
CRACKED THIS NOT.
AND BRIDGE THE DIFFERENCES
ACROSS THE PROGRAMS TO REALLY
TRY TO GET THE FOOD TO THE
FAMILIES AND HELP CHILDREN BE
READY TO LEARN THAT'S OUR GOAL
HERE AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BECKY GOES ON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS I'M AS YOU HEARD CAL FRESH
IS A REALLY CRITICAL SAFETY NET
FOR THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CHILDREN ACROSS CALIFORNIA AS
WELL AS THEIR FAMILIES.
WE KNOW THAT WHEN CHILDREN
LIVING IN LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
HAVE ACCESS TO CAL FRESH DO YOU
SEE A REDUCTION IN HEALTHCARE
COSTS -- THEY'RE MORE LIKELY TO
SUCCEED IN GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL AND ARE LESS LIKELY TO
DEVELOP HEART DISEASE AND OTHER
CHRONIC ILLNESSES LATER IN LIFE
SO WE KNOW THAT HOW FRESH WORKS
AND YET WE SEE A GAP IN CHILDREN
THAT ARE ACTUALLY ENROLLED IN
THE PROGRAM.
I'M SEVERAL FOOD BANKS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH ON THEIR COUNTY
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I'M AS KATHY MENTIONED HAVE
TRIED TO IMPLEMENT THE INTENT OF
AB -- FOR TO TO CONNECT CHILDREN
AFFRONT CREAM REDUCED PRICE
LUNCH TO CALL FRESH.
BUT THE PROCESS FOR ENTERING
INTO AMMO USE IN FINDING
EFFICIENT WAYS TO STREAMLINE
THOUGHT ENROLLMENT PROCESS HAVE
BEEN REALLY CHALLENGING AND WE
JUST HAVEN'T SEEN THE INTENDED
RESULTS THAT WE HAD ALL REALLY
HOPED FOR TOGETHER.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
MANY DATA AND TECHNICAL ISSUES
TO BE WORKED OUT I'M DOES THERE
IS NOT A SIMPLE SOLUTION TO THIS
WHICH IS WHY IT'S TAKEN SO LONG.
I'M IN SO WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO PARTICIPATING IN A
PROCESS TO REALLY PUT ALL THE
RIGHT HEADS TOGETHER TO FIGURE
OUT THE RIGHT WAY FOR IT SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JUST GO BIRTH
LOWER THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH
ESPINOSA ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
CARLY FINKEL WITH THE FOOD BANK
CONTRA COSTA IN SOLANO IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JEFF HARDY KIA PUBLIC ADVOCATE
AND PART OF THE COALITION.
THANK YOU IN SUPPORT YES.
SHOP THE PRASADA ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS YES MR MATH.
MISS WAY SAYS FROM SAYS --
OUTSTANDING BILL I KNOW THIS IS
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED OF OF
WORKED WITH -- THE PROPONENTS OF
THIS -- LOOKING AT THESE ISSUES
BEFORE -- I'D LOVE TO JOIN YOU
AS A CO AUTHOR.
ON THE SUBJECT.
I GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT IS A
NUMBER [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.%
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SINCE WE HAVE
A QUORUM GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKS.
IS NOT PART OF OUR COMMUNITY.
ALL RIGHT MISTER COOLEY.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
NO PROBLEM.
AND AS SOON AS OUR FIFTH MEMBER
ARRIVES I MAY START ROB ME OF
COURSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT SO ON AB FIVE THIRTY
SIX ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR I'M SORRY THAT IS NOT YOU
TWELVE TWENTY ONE I BELIEVE.
ITEM NUMBER.
THIRTEEN AB TWELVE TWENTY ONE
HAVE IS CORRECT [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
WHAT COLLEAGUES IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE HERE TODAY?
I'M HERE 2% A. B. TWELVE TWENTY
ONE RELATED.
TO CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER'S.
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER'S ARE
SICK OR CáC C. A. C. S..
BRING TOGETHER A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM OF INDIVIDUALS.
CURRENT LAW ENFORCEMENT CHOP
PROTECTION MEDICAL PERSONNEL
MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS IT
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO ENSURE
THAT IN RESPONSE TO AN
ALLEGATION OF CHILD ABUSE.
IS COORDINATED AMONG THOSE
AGENCIES.
AND THAT THE NEEDS OF THE CHILD
STAY AT THE FOREFRONT OF THE
INVESTIGATION -- WHEN YOU PUT
THOSE SORTS OF SERVICES TOGETHER
IN ONE PLACE WITH A FOCUS ON THE
CHILD'S WELL BEING?
THERE IS LESS TRAUMA THERE'S
MORE MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
PROVIDED TO THE CHILD.
AND OF WHEN NECESSARY THE
LIKELIHOOD OF GETTING A NEEDED
MEDICAL FORENSIC EXAM IS MUCH
HIGHER.
SO YOU PUT IT ALL TOGETHER AND
IT'S LESS TRAUMA AND MORE FACTS
EMERGE WHICH SUPPORTS WILL BE
THOSE CHILDREN.
OF THIS IS BEEN IDENTIFIES
PREFERRED MODEL FOR THE PURSUIT
OF JUSTICE AND HEALING FOR CHILD.
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
PRIMARILY A SEX TRAFFICKING.
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER DOESN'T
ACTUALLY HAVE A STATUTORY
DEFINITION OF WHAT CONSTITUTES A
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER.
CONSEQUENTLY THERE ARE NO
MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR THESE
SORTS OF FACILITIES.
YOU HAVE HERE.
ALL LOST WHAT SORRY ABOUT THAT.
SHOULD DRAW A BREATH.
ARM [inaudible]
AND OF THERE'S NO MINIMUM
STANDARDS AND CLARITY FOR
CHILDREN FAMILIES AND CHILD WAS
DIVESTITURES.
AS TO WHAT AND THEN THE CALL IN
ITSELF A CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
CENTER WILL PROVIDE -- THE BILL
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE CARRY BY
CHRISTOPHER REQUIREMENTS I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY ALLEY SU WHO.
WHO'S BEEN MY PARTNER BEFORE SHE
IS A SURVIVOR.
AND COLLEGE STUDENT.
IN A VERY ABLE WITNESS AND ALSO
ERIN HARPER WHO IS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN AFTER SEE
CENTERSOF CALIFORNIA.
AND CALICO.
WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
LISTENING INTERVIEWING
COORDINATION CENTER.
AND IT SERVES AS ALAMEDA COUNTY
CHILD ADVOCACY CENTER SO I
INVITE THEM TO JOIN ME NOW.
THE FIRST WITNESS.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME MY NAME
IS ERIN HARPER AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CCC AND
CALICO WHICH AS YOU JUST HEARD
IS THAT SEE SEE FOR ALAMEDA
COUNTY.
WE SERVE SIX HUNDRED TO SEVEN
HUNDRED CHILDREN HERE AGES TWO
THROUGH SEVENTEEN THREE QUARTERS
OF WHOM ARE VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
ABUSE.
CA SEES OUR CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY
CENTER'S OUR EVIDENCE BASED
TRAUMA INFORMED ORGANIZATIONS
THAT BRING TOGETHER EVERY
DISCIPLINE TASKED WITH
RESPONDING TO INITIAL DISCLOSURE
OF ABUSE LET'S LAW ENFORCEMENT
CHILD WELFARE PROSECUTION
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROVIDERS.
AT C. C.'S WE NOT ONLY BRING
TOGETHER EACH OF THESE
DISCIPLINES BUT WE PROVIDE A
SAFE SPACE WHERE CHILDREN CAN
RECEIVE.
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
NEUTRAL FORENSIC INTERVIEWS
WITHOUT A C. C. IT'S NOT
UNCOMMON FOR CHILDREN TO BE
INTERVIEWED ABOUT THEIR ABUSE UP
TO TWENTY ONE DIFFERENT TIMES BY
SEVENTEEN DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
WITH THE CA SEE THEIR
INTERVIEWED ONCE WITH A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM OBSERVING FROM
ANOTHER ROOM AND THAT INTERVIEW
IS RECORDED SO IT CAN BE
REFERRED TO BY ANYONE ELSE
BECOMING INVOLVED IN THE
INVESTIGATION LATER.
HE SEES ARE AND NATIONALLY --
TESTED AND PROVEN MODEL THERE
ARE OVER NINE HUNDRED CA SEES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY TWENTY
TWO ACCREDITED CDCS ARE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WITH CA SEASON PLACE RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN THAT CHILDREN ARE
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
RECEIVE THE APPROPRIATE MEDICAL
SERVICES THEY DESERVE. FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY TO BE REFERRED
TO MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
THEY ARE THE CRIMINAL IF IF
THEIR CASE GOES TO THROUGH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THEIR
CASE DISPOSITION IS FASTER SO
THERE IS A FAST RESULT FROM THE
START OF THE CRIMINAL CASE TO
THE END OF THE CASE.
PARENTS REPORT THAT THEIR
CHILDREN HAVE EXPERIENCE LESS
TRAUMA WHEN THEIR CHILDREN ARE
INVESTIGATED WHEN OUR CASES ARE
INVESTIGATED THROUGH SEAC AND
PARENTS REPORT GREATER
SATISFACTION WITH THOSE
INVESTIGATIONS.
IN ADDITION RESEARCH HAS SHOWN
THAT WHEN CASES ARE INVESTIGATED
THROUGH SEAC IN A COORDINATED
MANNER THEY COST THE COMMUNITY
ON AVERAGE ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
LESS PER CASE.
THIS IS A FAIRLY SIMPLE BELL IT
SETS A MINIMUM FLOOR OF WHAT AN
ORGANIZATION CALLING ITSELF A
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER
SHOULD PROVIDE.
THIS GIVES CLEAR TEACH CHILDREN
TO FAMILIES TO INVESTIGATORS TO
JUDGES TO DOCTORS AS TO WHAT
THEY SHOULD EXPECT FROM THE
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY CENTER.
SIMILAR TO THE PROTECTIONS THAT
ARE ALREADY PROVIDED. TO ADULT
SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS AS WITH
AS RAPE CRISIS CENTERS ARE HAVE
A DEFINITION AND A STANDARD IN
LEGISLATION OUR CHILDREN DESERVE
THE SAME PROTECTIONS.
AS I SAID THIS IS A SIMPLE BILL
BUT IT'S A GIANT STEP FORWARD
FOR CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO
PROVIDE JUSTICE AND HEALING TO
ALL OF HIS CHILDREN NO MATTER
WHERE THEY LIVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M ALLI LOU I'M
A NURSING STUDENT AT USF
UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE FOUNDER OF A STUDENT GROUP
CALLED.
PUSHY SEEM TO COMFORT HARZER
PATCH.
I FOUND A PATCH TO HELP CHILDREN
CRISES PARTICULARLY VICTIMS OF
CHILD ABUSE.
BY PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
STUFFED ANIMALS A COMFORT ITEM.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE
COLLECTED OVER TWO THOUSAND
STUFFED ANIMALS MOST OF WHICH
WERE DONATED CALICO CENTER TO
GIVE TO THE CHILDREN THEY SERVE.
I STARTED PATCH BECAUSE I WAS A
VICTIM OF CHILD ABUSE AND A
FORMER CLIENT OF CALICO.
WHEN I WAS SEVEN YEARS OLD I WAS
SEXUALLY ABUSED BYA FAMILY
FRIEND?
AT SUCH A YOUNG AGE IT WAS HARD
FOR ME TO PROCESS AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT HAPPENED TO ME.
BUT I KNEW THAT I'D BEEN HURT.
I WAS SCARED CONFUSED AND MOST
OF ALL I DIDN'T WANT TO TALK TO
ANYONE ABOUT IT.
AFTER A PARENT SUPPORT THE CASE
TO THE POLICE I REMEMBER BEING
BROUGHT TO CALICO WHERE I MET
WITH THEIR KIND AND CARING STUFF.
THE CALIBER TEAM HELP ME FEEL
SAFE AND LOVED WHICH ALLOWED ME
TO OPEN UP TO THEM ABOUT WHAT
HORRIBLE THINGS THAT HAPPENED TO
ME.
THEY WERE COMFORTING AND
ENCOURAGING AS EXPLAINED THE
SITUATION TO ME AND CONDUCTED
THEIR INTERVIEW USING TERMS THAT
I COULD UNDERSTAND.
EVEN TODAY ELEVEN YEARS LATER I
CAN STILL REMEMBER HOW IT FELT
SITTING IN THE BIG COMFY CHAIR
AND HUGGING MAY TEAL.
LARGE STUFFED BUNNY FINDING THE
COURAGE TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
POSED BY THE CALICO INTERFERES.
LOOKING BACK NOW I REALIZE HOW
FORTUNATE I WAS TO HAVE HAD A
CALICO CENTER IN MY COUNTY IF IT
WASN'T FOR THEIR TRAIN MULTI
DISCIPLINARY RESPONSE TEAM.
I WOULD HAVE BEEN INTERVIEWED
MANY TIMES BY DIFFERENT AGENCIES
FORCED TO RELIVE EASILY THE
WORST.
PART OF MY LIFE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
HOWEVER MANY VICTIMS OF CHILD
ABUSE ARE NOT AS FORTUNATE TO
HAVE THIS CENTER NEAR THEM TO
VISIT.
THIS IS WHY CAUCUS MODEL NEEDS
TO BE REPLICATED IN EVERY COUNTY
OF OUR STATE.
EVERY VICTIM OF CHILD ABUSE
DESERVE TO BE PROTECTED BY BEING
FURTHER VICTIMIZED BY THE
INVESTIGATORY PROCESS SOMETHING
WE CAN ONLY BE MADE POSSIBLE
THROUGH THE USE OF MULTI
DISCIPLINARY.
CHILD ADVOCATES THAT ADVOCACY
CENTERS LIKE CALICO.
THAT'S WHY I URGE YOU TO PLEASE
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF AB TOLD
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A PAUSE TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM PLEASE.
RATE EXCUSE ME RAY S. HERE
MATHIS HERE REVERSE.
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
GIPSON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY HI.
APPRECIATE THAT SINCERELY.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BY NAME IS CHIP TORTILLA AN
ADVOCATE.
AND MANY THINGS DIFFERENT FROM
FORTY YEARS AGO I ALSO WAS IN
THAT SHE WAS THE FOSTER PROGRAM
AND I YOU DESERVED SOME OF THE
THINGS TO DESCRIBE SO UNDERSTAND.
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS THAT
EIGHTEEN TO THE JOB THAT IS
NEEDED TO COULD NOT?
HAVE.
I'M SORRY TO SAY IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
TRY.
TO OBTAIN THE FAX.
THE FLOCK TO PRODUCE A LOT MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THAT.
SO AGAIN THAT'S MY TESTIMONY AND
ITS SUPPORT OF THIS.
AND THANK YOU CAN FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S HOLLY FLEMING I
WORK A CALICO AS A CHILD
INTERVIEW SPECIALIST AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HI I AM DOCTOR KATHY BOYLE AND I
WORK AT THE RESOURCE CONNECTION
CALAVERAS COUNTY CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY CENTER.
AS THE NURSE PRACTITIONER
FORENSIC INTERVIEWER AND CLINIC
MANAGER THE WORDS SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
AFTER THE MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THERESA ANDERSON WITH THE ARK IN
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATION AND SUPPORT.
CNN IF IN A CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
JUSTIN GET CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CRISTO NUMBER IT'S CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
THE BILL [inaudible]
SECOND.
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND -- LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
MR MATHIS MR COOLEY -- NEWS
OUTSTANDING BILL I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR HAVING THE COURAGE --
SHARE YOUR TESTIMONY -- HEY I
WANT TO GIVE THIS BILL THE
SUPPORT I FEEL THE DESERVES I'D
LOVE TO COME ON AS JOINT WITH
YOU TO SHOW THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
EFFORT AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
ABOUT A LIGHTED.
EDGE IF YOU HAVE ME ON THERE.
AT THE WHOLE COMMITTEE IF I HAD.
BUT NOW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE -- IT'S A VERY
SENSITIVE SITUATION NOW THAT
HAPPENS IN A HAS TO BE TREATED.
OTHER RIGHT WHERE IT CAN CAUSE A
SCORING FOR THE REST OF THE
LIVES OF THESE CHILDREN THAT GO
THROUGH THIS -- SO TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE IT SET UP IN THE RIGHT WAY --
WORDS JUST DONE ONCE -- SO IT'S
NOT A REPETITIVE PHAM.
I WOULD GO THROUGH THE EVENTS
OVER AND OVER -- TREMENDOUSLY
HELPS THE OUTCOMES.
CHAU LOOK FOR HELPING THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD THANK YOU ARE GOOD
THANK GOODNESS MATHIS.
MR COOLEY THAT THE IT THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT BILL WHEN I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THAT YOU
BROUGHT THIS FORWARD.
AND THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING OF THE WITNESSES
THAT ARE ABLE.
TO PUT A FACE TO WHY THIS IS
SUCH AN IMPORTANT ISSUE WHY A
YOUNG -- VICTIM SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO REPEAT THE STORY OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THANK YOU FOR NOT ONLY FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY BUT YOU'VE YOU'VE NOW
CREATED PATCH YOU NOW IS STUDENT
A NURSING STUDENT.
YOU ARE.
A GREAT TO SUCCESS.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR TAKING TIME
OUT OF YOUR LIFE TO BE HERE WITH
US AND TO PROVIDE THE TESTIMONY
ON MR COOLEY SPILL.
VERY GOOD WE HAVE A FIRST OF
FROM HIS FRIEDMAN SECOND FROM IS
REVERSE -- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS RANTS AYE
REYES AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I REVERSE.
REVERSE I JOIN [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
YES WONDERFUL FRIEDMAN AYE
GIPSON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
STONE.
IT'S FOUR ZERO WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE THE THE THE ROLE OPEN.
BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA GET AT LEAST
FIVE THANK YOU VERY MR COOLEY I
WOULD ALSO BE HONORED TO BE
ADDED ON AS A JOKE WHEN JOINT
WINS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL I
WANT TO POINT OUT TO YOU ALLEY.
YOU'RE AN ADVOCATE TODAY THE
CHAIR IS AN ADVOCATE SHE'S A
LAWYER.
SHE IS HAD A CAREER AS AN
ADVOCATE AND I THINK YOU WERE
WELL LAUNCHED ON ONE BOTH.
A SHE NOTES CREATING
ORGANIZATIONS.
BUT THEN COMING TO SACRAMENTO SO
I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE A
SECOND TIME.
THANK YOU ALSO AIRED.
YES THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
IN.
AB THIRTEEN OH ONE ALL RIGHT AND
BEFORE WE TAKE A BE THIRTEEN OH
ONE CAN WE GET A MOTION ON THIS
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE THE FIRST AND SECOND TO A
PLEASE TAKE ROLL ON AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WEEKS.
AND THAT'S TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
THANK YOU RAMOS I REYES AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS ON A REVERSE REAVIS I'D
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN STONE. FOUR ZERO
WILL LEAVE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ON ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB
TWELVE NINETY FIVE QUIRK SILVA.
CAN WE GET A MOTION.
REFERS TO THE SECOND.
HOUR PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RAMOS I REYES III
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO REMUS REMUS I CHOI.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
STONE.
THE VOTE CURRENT VOTERS THREE TO
ONE WILL LEAVE THAT ROLE OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLING ON ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN A. B..
THIRTEEN OH ONE YES COLLEAGUES
SO GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN -- I'M
DELIGHTED PERCENT A. B..
THIRTEEN OH ONE THIS FELIZ TO
PRIVATE ADOPTION FUNDING.
THE PRIVATE AGENCY ADOPTION
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM OTHERWISE
KNOWN AS PART.
SWING A LITTLE -- ACRONYM THEIR
PART.
WAS CREATED IN. NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR TO HELP INCENTIVIZE PRIVATE
ADOPTION FOR CHILDREN WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE REMAIN IN FOSTER CARE.
A CURRENTLY PRIVATE ADOPTION
AGENCIES ARE REIMBURSED UP TO
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER CHILD.
FOR COSTA WOULD OTHERWISE BE
REAM UNREIMBURSED WHEN AGENCIES
RECRUIT AND FIND A DOCTOR
FAMILIES.
SOARED CLEARLY SUPPORTS.
GETTING KIDS OUT OF FOSTER CARE
INTO ADOPTIVE HOUSEHOLDS.
AUSTIN'S PARK WAS CREATED IN
SEVENTY FOUR WE'VE SEEN MAJOR
CHANGES WITH THE TWENTY ELEVEN
REALIGNMENT.
AND CONTINUE OF CARE REFORM IN
CHILD WHERE FOR WELFARE.
HARPER JANGLY BUDGET FIFTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
BUT SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN IT HAS EXCEEDED THAT
FUNDING.
WHICH COUNTIES HAVE PAID FOR
EVEN KNOWS NOT PART OF THEIR
REALIGNMENT FUNNY SO COUNTIES
HAVE MORE OUTGO THAN THEY HAVE
BEEN PUT FORTH FROM THE STATE.
THIS BILL IS SEEKING.
TO RESTRUCTURE THE PART PROGRAM
TO CONTAIN COST TO COUNTIES.
WHILE THE SAME TIME PRESERVING
THIS MUCH NEEDED FUNDING
MECHANISM FOR PRIVATE OPTION
AGENCIES.
OF WHO DO A CRITICAL WORK A
CRITICAL WORK OF FINDING
PERMANENT FAMILY PATIENT FOR
CHILDREN IN NEED.
OF THE BILL COMES WILL TAKE ON
THE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
COMPENSATION ADOPTION AGENCIES.
FOR THE OTHERWISE UNREIMBURSED
COSTS.
OUR WASHER TO SOME OF THE
FUNDING FOR THE STATE DOWN THE
COUNTY LEVEL [inaudible]
OF I WANT TO SAY.
WE ARE ENGAGED IN A VERY ROBUST
PROCESS WITH THE PRIVATE
ADOPTION AGENCIES.
HOW THIS FINANCIAL WHAT
RIDERSHIP IS RESTRUCTURED IS A
MATTER OF GREAT CONSEQUENCE? TO
THE COUNTIES TO THE PRIVATE
OPTION AGENCIES.
ROLE TWENTY KIDS IN FOSTER CARE.
WHICH IS MY INTEREST IN THE
SUBJECT MATTER.
AND SO I DO WANT TO SAY I
CONSIDER THIS A WORK IN PROGRESS --
TO BUY OWN GRAND KIDS COME OUT
OF THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM AND IN
THIS COUNTY.
I CERTAINLY INTEND TO GET RIGHT
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THAT WORK.
SO I HAVE WITH ME TODAY CATHY
SUNDERLAND'S OF THE COUNTY WILL
FOR DRUG SO SHE'S BECAUSE
SUPPORT.
AND HAVE OTHER ANSWERED PARTIES
ARE NOR HERE SO KATHY.
THANK YOU FOR SWEETNESS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
KATHY CENTERING WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
AS A MISTER COOLEY NOTED
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR WAS A LONG
TIME AGO A LOT HAS CHANGED IN
THE WORLD AND IN PARTICULAR TO
RESET CHANGES THAT HE MENTIONED
THE TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT.
OF THE BASICALLY THE ENTIRE
CHILD WELFARE AND FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM TO COUNTIES.
AS A PART OF THIS REALIGNMENT
THE FUNDING -- FOR PART WAS
ACTUALLY REALIGNED COUNTIES BUT
THERE WAS REALLY NO MECHANISM
FOR INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES TO BE
ABLE TO ENTER INTO CONTRACTS OR
AMMO USE WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
AGENCIES.
AND RATHER THAN BECAUSE
WHOLESALE DESTRUCTION AT THAT
TIME EIGHT YEARS AGO WE
TEMPORARILY -- CREATED A
STRUCTURE WHERE THE STATE WOULD
CONTINUE TO BE ABLE TO DRAW UPON
THE REALIGNMENT RESOURCES AND
PAY THOSE CLAIMS.
THE IDEA OF THE WAS WE WOULD
FIGURE OUT AT SOME POINT HOT IT
YOU KNOW SORT OF CHANGE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY TO THE COUNTIES.
THE ISSUE HAS BEEN HASTENED BY
THE OVERAGE IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED BUT ALSO THERE'S
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT'S
BEING PROPOSED BY THE STATE. TO
ENABLE IT TO CONTINUE BILLING
THOSE COUNTIES WE HAVE BEEN
PAYING THE BILLS SORT OF AS A
COURTESY AGAIN ON A TEMPORARY
BASIS.
AND THE BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
WOULD WE CANNOT CODIFY IT BUT
SORT OF MAKE THAT AN ONGOING
ISSUE AND WE REALIZE THAT WE
REALLY NEED TO TRY TO GET
LEGISLATION GOING. TO WORK WITH
THE ADOPTION AGENCY THEN AFTER
PHASE THAT ACT AS AGENCIES TO
PRESERVE THE PART PROGRAM BUT
MOVE FORWARD TO GET THAT DOWN TO
THE COUNTY LEVEL SO THAT WERE
THE ONES AUTHORIZING IT -- WE
HOPE AS PART OF THE PLACEMENT
AGREEMENTS THAT ALREADY EXIST
WE'RE NOT ASKING THESE AGENCIES
TO ENTER INTO INDIVIDUAL
CONTRACTS OF THE COUNTIES THAT
OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE UNWIELDY.
BUT WE THINK THAT WE CAN DO IT
IN SUCH A WAY THAT IS NOT AND
WE'LL BE THAT IT PRESERVES PARK.
AND ALSO -- ADDRESSES ONE OTHER
ISSUE THAT'S COME UP WITH THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM BIG
ACTED SEVERAL YEARS AGO --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE'S
LEGISLATION WHAT THAT DID WAS GO
STATEWIDE WITH WHAT'S CALLED THE
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL PROCESS
AND WHAT THAT DOES IS IT MOVES A
LOT OF THE ADOPTION WORK.
UP FRONT AND COUNTIES ARE DOING
THAT AS PART OF OUR APPROVAL OF
THOSE RESOURCE FAMILY.
THINGS LIKE A AN ADOPTION HOME
STUDY ARE NOW DONE AS PART OF
THAT PSYCHOSOCIAL ASSESSMENT
THAT THE COUNTIES DO ALREADY AS
PART OF OUR FAA.
SO WHAT WE'RE THINKING IS GOING
TO HAPPEN OVER TIME IS THAT THAT
WORK WON'T NEED TO BE DONE AS
MUCH BY THE PRIVATE ADOPTION
AGENCIES AN EFFORT FACED.
AND THIS COULD END UP WELL WE'VE
SEEN OVER JUST FOR THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND ACTUALLY THING UNDER
SPENDING AND THOSE FUNDS BUT
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE TIED UP THERE
AT THE STATE LEVEL THERE THERE
FOR THAT PART PROGRAM AND THAT'S
IT.
PARK ONLY HAS CERTAIN USES AND
ITS RELATED SPECIFICALLY TO
ADOPTIONS SO ALSO WITH THE BILL
WHAT DO YOU AND MOVING THE FUNDS
TO THE COUNTIES WOULD ALLOW US
TO USE THAT -- IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH THESE AGENCIES WE VALUE
VERY MUCH TO DO OTHER PLACEMENT
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES GUARDIANSHIP
SUPPORT ON IT COULD BE PRE PRE
OR POST PERMANENCY.
TRYING TO MAINTAIN AN ADOPTIVE
FAMILY OR MAINTAIN A
GUARDIANSHIP WE LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO FREE UP THOSE FUND SHOULD
THAT UNDER SPENDING OCCUR LIKE
WE THINK IT COULD BUT HAVEN'T
YET SEEN. TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT --
WE'VE TRIED VERY STRONGLY TO
ADDRESS AT LEAST AS MANY AS WE
COULD OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED BY THE ADVOCATES --
AND THE AGENCIES AS WELL AS THE
ALLIANCE WHO I THINK WILL
PROBABLY HEAR FROM AND ARE VERY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM WE DON'T WANT TO PLOT
THE RUG OUT FROM UNDER THESE
AGENCIES.
WE JUST THINK REALIGNMENT
HAPPENED SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND
WE IT IS TIME TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MOVE THIS PROGRAM DOWN TO THE
COUNTY LEVEL BUT KEEP IT WORKING
AND EXPAND ITS USE OF POSSIBLE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
AGAIN JEFF TORTILLA JUST PRIVATE
ADVOCATE TENDS TO CONCERNED IN
PLEASE SOMETHING THAT HELPS IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WORKS.
BIG DIFFERENCE FROM [inaudible]
NINETEEN SEVENTY THANK YOU.
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS CONCERN
MOSTLY SUPPORT CAN CONCERN IS
THIS THE RIGHT HOLE FOR GREAT
ABSOLUTELY.
OF MADAM CHAIR HEY IT SEEMS TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M DOCTOR
GAIL JHONSON VON.
AN INDEPENDENT PERMANENCY
ADVOCATES UP WORKING OVER THE
LAST THIRTY FOUR YEARS TO REMOVE
THE BARRIERS TO PREVENT OUR
CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE FROM
ACHIEVING AND SUSTAINING
PERMANENT FAMILIES.
I SUPPORT THE BILL.
AS IF THE INTENTIONS OF THE BILL
BUT MY CONCERN.
IS AROUND HOW IT'S CURRENTLY
WRITTEN.
BEFORE THE TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN LEGISLATION THAT CREATED
THE LANGUAGE THAT THE PARK
STATUTE CURRENTLY HAS.
MY SMALL AGENCY WHERE I WAS
PREVIOUSLY.
LOS FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
EVERY CHILD WE PLACED FOR
ADOPTION.
THE YEAR PREVIOUS YEAR WE HAD
PLACED TWO HUNDRED HARD TO PLACE
CHILDREN INTO ADOPTED FAMILIES
NOT TWO HUNDRED TIMES FIVE
THOUSAND IS A MILLION DOLLAR
LOSS.
AS WE WATCH AGENCIES AROUND THE
STATE RELINQUISHING THEIR
ADOPTION LICENSES BECAUSE OF
THIS WE OURSELVES SERIOUSLY
CONSIDERED SHOULD WE STOP
PROVIDING THOSE SERVICES.
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
LEGISLATION MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR
US TO CONTINUE AND IN FACT.
FOLLOWING AT THE NUMBER OF F. F.
A.'S THAT.
ACHIEVEMENT ADOPTION LICENSES
INCREASED BY 77% LEADING TO A
LARGE INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN THE PERCENTAGE OF
CHILDREN EXITING FOSTER CARE TO
ADOPTION.
I KNOW THAT. THIRTEEN AB
THIRTEEN A ONE IS WELL
INTENTIONS AND I HAVE GREAT
ESTEEM FOR THE PEOPLE SITTING AT
THIS TABLE WE ARE COLLEAGUES
FROM LONG BACK.
BUT I HAVE GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT
THE REMOVING OF THE CLARITY OF
THE AMOUNT OF COMPENSATION
ADOPTION AGENCY CAN RECEIVE FOR
THEIR DOCUMENTED UNREIMBURSED
COSTS ARE NONPROFIT AGENCIES
SIMPLY CAN'T CONTINUE THIS WORK
WITH A BUSINESS MODEL THAT
REQUIRES THEM. TO DO WORK AT A
LOSS.
AGENCIES ALL AROUND THE STATE
RIGHT NOW ARE CONSIDERING.
CLOSING THEIR ADOPTION PROGRAMS
IF AB.
THIRTEEN OH ONE IT ENDS UP
REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
COMPENSATION THAT THEY CAN
ACHIEVE UNDER.
THAT UNDER PAR.
THE TO TAKE THESE CHILDREN
REALLY MATTER AND I URGE YOU AND
THEY IF THEY'RE WITH US I URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER REMOVING THE
AMENDMENT.
THAT DELETES THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE SPECIFYING THAN THE
LEVEL OF COMPENSATION THAT CAN
BE RECEIVED FOR THESE
UNREIMBURSED COST I HAVE GREAT
GRATITUDE TO MR COOLEY AND HIS
STAFF.
THEIR CONTINUED WORK TO OPEN THE
PATHWAYS TO PERMANENCY FOR THESE
CHILDREN SO THAT THEY CAN
ACHIEVE THEIR THEIR POTENTIAL
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO BEING.
AN TO SEEN AMENDMENTS THAT CAN
ALLOW ME TO HAVE MY FULL SUPPORT
BEHIND THIS BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OTHER WITNESSES.
IN BETWEEN OR IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SHARE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHRIS
STONER MERTZ WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES -- WHEN WE REPRESENT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED NON PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS?
INCLUDING FIFTEEN NON PROFIT
PRIVATE FOSTER CARE AND ADOPTION
AGENCIES IN CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE DOES NOT OF
AN OFFICIAL OPPOSE POSITION BUT
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN SO FAR AND WE
ARE HAVING A ROBUST CONVERSATION.
AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT --
ON BEHALF OF THE AUTHOR OF HIS
STAFF AND SEE WGA THE SPONSOR.
AB THIRTEEN OH ONE SIX TO CHANGE
AND ELIMINATE THE ADOPTION
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR A
SUCCESSFUL FORTY FIVE YEAR OLD
PROGRAM WITHOUT CREATING A NEW
RATE STRUCTURE.
AS BACKGROUND OVER SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED CHILDREN ARE ADOPTED IN
CALIFORNIA EACH YEAR AND THREE
QUARTERS OF ALL ADOPTIONS
FINALIZED IN CALIFORNIA ARE FROM
FOSTER CARE.
THAT IS AN AMAZING STORY ABOUT
THE SUCCESS WE'VE HAD IN
CALIFORNIA FINDING PERMANENCY
FOR OUR FOSTER YOUTH OUR PRIMARY
CONCERN IS TO ENSURE THAT
NOTHING.
IS DONE TOO QUICKLY THAT WILL
HAVE THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF LOWERING NOT THAT HIGH
SUCCESS RATE.
AMONG CALIFORNIA'S ADOPTIVE
CHILDREN.
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS THE
PERCENTAGE OF FOSTER YOUTH TO
EXIT THE CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM TO
ADOPTION HAS INCREASED 24%.
AND 25% OF ADOPTIONS FROM FOSTER
CARE ARE RECRUITED IN PLACE BY
PRIVATE NONPROFIT FOSTER FAMILY
AGENCIES OR FFA IS.
AN ADOPTION AGENCIES
SPECIFICALLY WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE BILL THAT
ELIMINATES THE CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE DOES NOT
HAVE THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF DISRUPTING THE SUCCESS OF
PART.
PURPOSE THE ONLY FUNDING SOURCE
FOR PRIVATE NONPROFIT ADOPTION
AGENCIES AND IS ALSO THE ONLY
PERFORMANCE BASED OUT COME
PROGRAM IN OUR STATE'S CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM WHEREBY THE
PAYMENT TO THE NONPROFIT
ADOPTION AGENCY. FOR THEIR
OTHERWISE UNREIMBURSED COSTS.
ONLY COMES AFTER AN ADOPTION
PLACEMENT AGREEMENT IS SIGNED
AND THEN.
THE SECOND HALF AFTER
FINALIZATION OF THAT ADOPTION WE
HAVE TWO MAJOR CONCERNS THE BILL
NEEDS TO ENSURE THAT A COUNTY
PLACES A FOSTER CHILD.
THAT WHEN IT COUNTY PLACES A
FOSTER CHILD WITH A FAMILY THAT
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY A DULY AS A
DULY LICENSED FFA AN ADOPTION
AGENCY THAT AGENCY SHOULD BE
REIMBURSED FOR OTHERWISE ON
REIMBURSE COSTS.
AND THEN SECONDLY THERE NEEDS TO
BE SUFFICIENT DATA AND TIME
GIVEN TO RECONSTRUCTING THE PART
PROGRAM. TO CONTINUE THE SUCCESS
OF A CHEERING TIMELY AND QUALITY
PERMANENCY FOR CHILDREN IN OUR
SYSTEM.
AGAIN WE THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSOR FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS THUS FAR AND LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER DISCUSSION.
TO GET TO A A GOOD PLACE FOR
THAT WILL WORK FOR ALL OF US IN
MOSTLY FOR THE KIDS.
THANKS THANK YOU.
HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JILL JACOBSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF FAMILY
BUILDERS BY ADOPTION WE'RE BASED
IN OAKLAND WE SERVE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA -- I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL ALSO --
WE'VE WORKED COLLABORATIVELY
WITH CW DA FOR MANY YEARS AND I
HOPE WE CONTINUE TO DO THAT AND
ASSEMBLY MAN I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE LEADERSHIP OF YOU AND YOUR
STAFF IN DOING THAT.
MY CONCERN IS FOR THE CHILDREN --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT PRIVATE
ADOPTION AGENCIES HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO DO BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE SOME
OF THE BURDENS THAT THE COUNTIES
HAVE.
IS WE'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE A BIT MORE INNOVATIVE WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO RECRUIT AND PREPARE FAMILIES
TO MEET THE VERY SPECIAL NEEDS
OF MANY OF THE CHILDREN IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
THAT INCLUDES LARGE SIBLING
GROUPS OF CHILDREN AND I MEAN
THREE STEPS FOR SIPS FIVE SIPS
AND FOR SOME REASON IN LA COUNTY
EIGHT SIBLING GROUPS THE EIGHTH
KIDDOS AND ONE SIBLING GROUP --
IT'S MY HOME CITY I DON'T KNOW
WHY WE GROW THEM SO BIG THERE
BUT WE DO.
SIBLING GROUPS ALSO -- LESBIAN
GAY BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER
CHILDREN AREN'T REPRESENT 20% OF
THE POPULATION OF OF CHILDREN IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
AND WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CREATE INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS AND
SYSTEMS WE WERE ALSO THE FIRST
ORGANIZATIONS TO WELCOME LESBIAN
AND GAY FAMILIES INTO.
OF THE FOLD AS PROSPECTIVE
ADOPTIVE ANNA UP IN FOSTER
PARENTS AND THEY NOW REPRESENT A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF CARE
GIVERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BOTH IN PUBLIC AND AND PRIVATE
AGENCIES WE'VE HAD THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES IF WE DON'T
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE FUNDING
THAT WE'VE HAD WE'RE GOING TO
LOSE THAT.
AND THE CHILDREN THAT ARE GOING
TO SUFFER ARE THE OLDER CHILDREN
BECAUSE THOSE OF THE MAJORITY OF
THE CHILDREN WHO HAVE THE
CHALLENGES AND GET STUCK IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
SO CHILDREN OVER AGE NINE TEN
AND OP BUT PARTICULARLY
TEENAGERS SIBLING GROUPS ARE
GOING TO BE BROKEN UP KIDS ARE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO STAY WITH
THEIR SIBLINGS.
MOST OF THE CHILDREN THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OUR CHILDREN OF
COLOR THEIR BLACK AND BROWN.
AND THEIR CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS DEVELOPMENTALLY LEARNING
WISE AND PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY IN MENTAL HEALTH
WISE AND WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE CHILDREN DON'T
BECOME OUR NEXT GENERATION OF
HOMELESS YOUNG PEOPLE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN BETWEEN
OR IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KAREN
ALFORT IN THE C. E. O. FOR LILY
PUT FAMILIES OUR WE'RE A
STATEWIDE ADOPTION AGENCY AND
HAVE DONE NEARLY TEN THOUSAND
ADOPTIONS FROM FOSTER CARE SINCE
NINETEEN NINETY WHEN WE A I
APPRECIATE -- BOTH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSOR FOR THE
RECEPTIVENESS TO WORKING THROUGH --
THE CONCERNS THAT WE EXPRESSED
WITH THE INITIAL LANGUAGE AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
DIALOGUE AND AND I'M AND I
BELIEVE THAT ARE HARD AT ALL
WITH.
WE WANT OUR CHILDREN NOT TO GROW
UP IN FOSTER CARE NOT TO BE PART
OF A SYSTEM A PART OF A FAMILY
SITE THANK YOU FOR ON THE
ONGOING DIALOGUE AND LOOK
FORWARD -- TO I HOPE GETTING TO
A PLACE WHERE I COULD STAND
CONFIDENTLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- HI MY NAME IS
GORDON RICHARDS AND I'M WITH A
PROFOUNDLY SERVICES I WON'T
REPEAT THE THE WORK THE CHRIS
AND CAROLINE OTHERS HAVE DONE.
OF JUST SAY I HAVE CONCERNS AND
AND LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IN COLLABORATION
WITH THE ALLIANCE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE THE FIRST A CAN I GET
A MOTION.
CAN USE THAT SPRING A BACK ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE [inaudible]
YES.
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
TAKING ON A DIFFICULT ISSUE AND
I HOPE YOU TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH.
THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO MAKE
SURE THAT THERE'S NO ON
INTENSIVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES SURELY OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE.
ON THE SAME PAGE IN TERMS OF
YOUR GOALS -- I JUST -- CAN'T
LET THE OPPORTUNITY GO BY TO SAY
THAT -- MY HOPE THAT THE
COUNTIES -- CONTINUE TO WORK ON
REMOVING BARRIERS THAT KEEP
PEOPLE.
I'M OUT OF THE ADOPTION PROCESS --
YOU KNOW THE SYSTEM IS -- VERY
UNFRIENDLY TO ADOPTIVE PARENTS.
AND YOU KNOW I HOPE THAT THE
COUNTIES RESENTMENT THERE ARE
ANTI ADOPTION BIASES AND WORK ON
THE PARENTS SIDE AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN.
I THINK THE COMMENTS IT WHAT
WHAT I APPRECIATED IS THAT THERE
WASN'T ANYONE WHO SAID I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
THERE WERE CONCERNS AND EVERYONE
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THEY'VE CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU MISTER
COOLEY AND I THINK THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
AS MS FRIEDMAN HAS INDICATED WE
DO WANT TO BE SURE THAT WE TAKE
CARE OF THOSE.
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND MAKE
SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
AND TO THE THE PRIVATE ADOPTION --
AGENCIES WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
THEY CONTINUE TO BE ABLE. TO TO
BE PART OF THE SPACE AND TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE INCLUDED SO
WITH THAT.
WE HAVE -- A FIRST OF MOTION BY
MS RIVAS SECOND BY MISS FRIEDMAN
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST WANT TO SAY I THINK.
WHEN I THINK OF THIS BILL I
THINK OF A SERMON HER LONG TIME
AGO?
THE TITLE OF WHICH WAS THE SEVEN
LAST WORDS OF THE CHURCH.
AND I ALWAYS ASK MYSELF WHAT THE
HECK OF THE SURPLUS WERE TO THE
CHURCH.
TURNED OUT THEY WERE WE'VE NEVER
DONE IT THIS WAY BEFORE.
I THINK ANY SORT OF
ORGANIZATIONS VITAL NEEDS TO BE
LOOKING AT INNOVATIONS WERE
ACTUALLY APPRECIATED THAT.
PERSPECTIVE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF GROUND BREAKING INNOVATION
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE SYSTEM.
AND I ACTUALLY FEEL THIS BILL IS
SIMPLY A PART OF THAT.
EFFORT AND INNOVATION WE'RE
UNDER FINANCIAL PRESSURE.
ALL I AM LOOKING TO SUPPORT THE
COUNTIES BRAG SAID TOOK SYDNEY
TO THE MIDWEST LAST WEEK.
AND THE ONE PIECE OF HOME LIFE
TO FOLLOW US WHERE WE GO WAS A
YOUNG COUPLE WE KNEW.
THEY WERE GOING TO A COUNTY
ADOPTION PROCESS IN GOING.
TO COURT PROCESS WITH GREAT
ANXIETY THAT WE ARE KEEPING TABS
ON SO I SORT OF APPRECIATE THAT
PERSPECTIVE -- FROM MY COLLEAGUE
SO.
I'M JUST PLEASED TO BRING THIS
BILL I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE PARTIES.
AND BE ASSURED BY FOCUSES UPON
HOW TO MAKE THESE RESOURCES.
THAT WE COMMIT ON WHATEVER FRONT.
OF HAVE A LASTING POSITIVE
IMPACT THE LIVES OF KIDS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD TECH WORLD PLEASE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RAMOS I REYES III
MATHIS.
MATH IS NOT VOTING BRAVE US
[inaudible]
RIVERSIDE CHOI.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I GIPSON
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN STONE [inaudible]
STONE I THE FERVOR FOR VOTES --
OF WE WILL LEAVE THE RECORD OPEN
VERY GOOD THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
RIGHT IN SIGNED IN ORDER MISTER
GRAYSON.
PRESENTING ON ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AB.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I WOULD
START BY THINKING AT THANKING
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS BILL.
AND ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
I ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED.
LAST YEAR THE LIVING CHILDREN
FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY TASK
FORCE SUBMITTED THE REPORT ON
STRATEGIES AND RECOMMENDATIONS
TO END DEEP.
CHILD POVERTY IN REDUCE OVERALL
CHILD POVERTY BY 50% AND OUR
STATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN TWENTY ONE
WILL DO JUST THAT BY
ESTABLISHING A GRANT PROGRAM TO
FIND SUPPORTIVE SERVICES FOR LOW
INCOME WORKFORCE AND EDUCATION --
PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS IN ONE
REPORT 99% OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM OFFICIALS
STATED.
THAT THEY WANTED TO PROVIDE MORE
SUPPORT SERVICES BUT ONLY ONE
THIRD SAID THEY WERE LIKELY TO
EXPAND THOSE SERVICES IN THE
FUTURE.
SO TO ELABORATE JUST A LITTLE
MORE I HAVE A WITNESS THAT
ALLOWED TO SELF INTRODUCE
[inaudible]
WITNESS.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY
NAME IS JACKIE TO WHOM LONG I'M
THE VICE PRESIDENT POLICY AND
HAVE A SEAT AT THE GRACE
INSTITUTE -- ON PROVIDING TEST
MONEY ON BEHALF OF CON MAKE
COLLEGE WHO IS THE CO CHAIR OF
WHAT THE CULTURE OF THE LIFTING
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES OUT OF
POVERTY TASK FORCE SO -- I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE STAFF -- AND
CHAIR ON ON MAKING VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
ON THE FACT THAT YOU'RE MAKING
THIS A A MORE IMPROVED AND
BETTER BILL.
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THE LEGISLATIVE CHARGE OF THE
CHILD PARTY TASK FORCE WAS
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE EVIDENCE
BASED PLAN TO SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE CALIFORNIA'S.
HIGHEST IN THE NATION LEVEL OF
CHILD AND FAMILY PARTY FOR
ANALYTICAL PURPOSES THE TASK
FORCE FURTHER DELINEATED THIS
GOAL AS A LIMITING DEEP
CHILDHOOD POVERTY AND REDUCING
OVERALL CHILD APART IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT LEAST 50% OVER THE NEXT TEN
TO TWENTY YEARS. TO HELP
ACCOMPLISH THIS THAT -- WE
DIVIDE THE TASK FORCE INTO
SUBCOMMITTEES.
INCLUDING A SOCIAL SAFETY NET
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
EDUCATION WORKFORCE AND TRAINING
SPECIAL SPECIAL POPULATIONS
ACCORDED SERVICES.
THE CALIFORNIA IT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WHAT WAS REPRESENTED
AS PART OF THIS TASK FORCE --
AND ALSO WITH AN ACTIVE MEMBER
AND CHAIR OF EDUCATION WERE
PERSON TRAINING SUBCOMMITTEE.
THE WORK FOR SOME CAN'T
COMMITTEE START WITH ACTUALLY TO
PROMISES.
FIRST AT THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY TO BE STRONG AND TO
REDUCE CHILD AND FAMILY POVERTY.
JOBS NEEDED TO JOB NEED TO BUT
BE BOTH AVAILABLE AND PAY A
LIVING WAGE -- SECOND THAT
EMPLOYMENT OF THIS TYPE IS THE
BEST SUSTAINED ROUTE OUT OF
POVERTY.
THEY ALSO CONSIDERED OVERARCHING
ISSUES LIKE THE PREDICTABILITY
OF OURS AND SHIFTS TO AND THE
IMPACT OF AUTOMATION AND THE
DIGITAL AND SERVICE ECONOMIES.
THE SUB COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
SUBCOMMITTEE STRONGLY EMPHASIZE
THAT THE SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT
THING THAT COULD BE DONE IN THE
WORK FORCE AND TRAINING AREA
WOULD BE TO REMOVE THE BARRIERS
TO PARTICIPATION.
AND COMPLETION WORKFORCE
TRAINING PROGRAMS BY LOW INCOME
PARTICIPANTS BY FUNDING SERVICES
LIKE CHILDCARE TRANSPORTATION
AND ACCESS TO THE STATE SAFETY
NET AND SOCIAL SERVICES.
PROGRAMS AVAILABLE TO THEM.
AS THE NOW SAYS AND THE RESEARCH
POINTS IT IS PARTICULARLY
IMPACTFUL FOR WOMEN WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN AND WE KNOW THAT
APPROXIMATELY CLOSE 270% OF THEM
HAVE CHILDREN.
UNDER -- UNDER THE AGES OF SIX
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT FOR
TRAINING AND JOB TRAINING.
PROGRAMS TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
TRAINEES NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET
TO AND FROM WORK HAVE RELIABLE
CHILDCARE AND HOUSING SECURITY
THE SUBCOMMITTEE RECOMMENDED THE
SEPARATE FUND.
BE ESTABLISHED BETWEEN THE
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
THIS PURPOSE AS A PRIORITY
RECOMMENDATION.
IT WAS UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED BY
THE FULL TASK FORCE AND I A
URGENT AYE VOTE. TO ENSURE THAT
FAMILIES CAN LIFT THEMSELVES OUT
OF POVERTY.
A COMPLETE THESE TRAINING
PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
RIGHT.
CARLY SINGLE AT THE FOOD BANK OF
CONTRA COSTA IN SOLANO IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND SAN FRANCISCO JEWISH
VOCATIONAL SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KEVIN IN SCOPE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
SEAN TIAS RUN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
MATHIS A SECOND BY MISS FRIEDMAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU PLEASE TAKE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I AM
MATHIS.
MATHIS ON A REVERSE REVERSE I'D
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE.
STONE AYE. FIVE ZERO YOUR BILL
IS OUT BUT WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MS GARCIA.
ON ITEM NUMBER TWO AB.
ONE SIX THREE THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS ON A START BY THANKING
US STAFF YOURSELF FOR WORKING
WITH US.
ON THIS BILL WE'VE ALL SEEN IN
THE NEWS ABOUT CHILDREN BEING
SEPARATED.
AND A LOT OF US WERE HEARTBROKEN
BY THAT AND WE'RE LEFT IN THE
QUESTION OF WHAT CAN WE DO
SOMEWHERE TOO AND WE ASK THE
QUESTIONS ONLY THIRTY TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE AYE AYE TO COMBAT
AND MINERS COMING.
ON AND SO IN THAT.
IN THAT VEIN OF ASKING WHAT CAN
WE DO -- WE DISCOVERED THAT
CHILDREN WERE BEING PLACED IN
FACILITIES AND THEN WE PICKED UP
THE PHONE AND SAID WHAT ARE THE
FACILITIES LIKE AND HOW MANY
CHILDREN DO YOU HAVE AND HOW WE
TAKING CARE AND THEN TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE OKAY AND THEY'RE
NOT BEING ME TOM A TIES.
WE HAD A LOT OF WALLS ALONG THE
WAY WE CAN GET ANY INFORMATION.
BUT WE DID LEARN THAT THESE
FACILITIES HAD TO BE LICENSE
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
IS A FROM THERE WE DECIDED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO LEVERAGE --
THAT LICENSE TO MAKE SURE THE
KIDS WERE GETTING WHAT THEY
NEEDED TO BE TAKEN CARE OF WE'VE
IN EVEN MORE TROUBLE AS WE CARE
ABOUT.
CHILDREN NOT BEING FAIR HOW MANY
CHILDREN ARE IN CUSTODY HOW MANY
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN SEPARATED WE
THINK IT'S BEING SICK AND SOME
OF THEM DYING IN CUSTODY.
OUT THERE INTO THAT URGENCY GREW
FURTHER AND SO BACK TO THINKING
THAT COMMITTEE WHILE I'M NOT AN
EXPERT AND I COULDN'T FIGURE OUT
HOW TO LEVERAGE JUST AND YOU WE
HAD A TOOL THAT WE KILL
EVERYTHING SO I APPRECIATE.
THAT TODAY AND THAT'S WHAT YOU
HAVE BEFORE YOU WITH AB ONE
SIXTY THREE OUT THERE -- AND SO
AB ONE SIXTY THREE SOUTH CREATE
A FACILITIES LIAISON POSITION TO
CONNECT VARIOUS STYLES OF
HOUSING THESE CHILDREN.
ARE PLACED IN WITH SUPPORT AND
SERVICES INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO LEGAL SERVICES MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ASSESSMENTS.
AND PUBLIC BENEFITS THEY WILL
ARRANGE MEETINGS FOR EACH AND
DOCUMENTS AND IMMIGRANT MINOR
WHO QUALIFY WITH A QUALIFIED
ORGANIZATION THAT WILL PROVIDE
LEGAL SERVICES WE ALREADY HAVE
MONIES IN THE BUDGET FOR THESE
DEAL SERVICES WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THEM.
THE FACILITIES THE LIAISON WILL
SELL WORK WITH THE COUNTY CHILD
WORK WELL FOR AGENCIES AND
COUNTY HUMAN SERVICES AGENCIES
TO IDENTIFY SUPPORT.
AND SERVICES AND CONNECT
LICENSES TO BILL SUPPORT
SERVICES AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I'VE BILL AND WITH
ME TO THEIR HAVE REBEKAH ONE
SALAS.
WHO REPRESENTS THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS WHO HAS
PREPARED A STATEMENT?
THE FIRST WITNESS GOOD AFTERNOON
REBEKAH GONZALEZ AGAIN WITH ANY
US W. CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB ONE SIXTY THREE WHICH
WILL CREATE A FACILITIES LIAISON
POSITION WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO ASSIST
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH.
WHO RESIDE IN A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS CONTROLLED BY THE STATE
THE FOUR THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN RELEASED TO SPONSORS
AND FISCAL YEAR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SHOW THE NEED TO COORDINATE
SERVICES FOR THESE CHILDREN? TO
MAKE SURE THAT NO CHILD FALLS
THROUGH THE CRACKS WE HAVE ALL
HEARD THE HORROR STORIES OF
CHILDREN BEING ABUSED AND
FACILITIES WE CANNOT LET THIS
HAPPEN IN CALIFORNIA.
UNDOCUMENTED YOU HAVE EXPERIENCE
SIGNIFICANT TRAUMA AS A RESULT
OF THEIR JOURNEY AND AS A RESULT
OF BEING SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS AND FAMILIES.
THESE VULNERABLE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH DESERVE OUR SUPPORT.
AS A RESULT OF THEIR TRAUMA
THESE CHILDREN NEED A VARIETY OF
SETTINGS TO ENSURE THERE ARE
CERTAIN VARIETY OF SERVICES
EXCUSE ME TO INSURE THEIR
WELLBEING.
FIRST AND FOREMOST THEY WILL
NEED TRAUMA INFORMED TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES WHICH MAY ALSO
INCLUDE A SCREENING TO SEE IF
THEY HAVE BEEN A VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
SECOND THEY MAY NEED MEDICAL
SERVICES TO ENSURE THEIR
PHYSICAL HEALTH THIRD
IMMIGRATION RELATED LEGAL
SERVICES SHOULD BE PROVIDED TO
ALL AND ACCOMPANIED CHILDREN AND
THOSE SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
LASTLY WE MUST ENSURE THAT THESE
CHILDREN ARE ENROLLED IN SCHOOL
AND THAT THEY RECEIVE ANY OTHER
SERVICES THAT THEY MAY BE
ENTITLED.
TO IN SUMMARY THE LIAISON
POSITION WITHIN DSS WILL HELP TO
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN PLACED IN
THE STATE ARE IN SAFE AND
APPROPRIATE SETTINGS AND THAT
THEIR PLACEMENTS ARE ADEQUATELY
EQUIPPED. TO MEET THE MEDICAL
MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER SPECIAL
NEEDS OF THESE CHILDREN.
THIS BILL WILL HELP PROTECT THE
CHILDREN AND THEREFORE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES [inaudible]
IN SUPPORT.
MARILYN MY PM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF GENESIS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KEVIN IN SCOPE FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITNESSES [inaudible]
YES.
RUBBER MOLLY HAWES AND TAMALE
CALIFONIA AND GENESIS OF THE
TRI VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND I'M JUST WAIT.
IS THIS LADY WAS ONES IN SIXTY
THREE YES.
YES WE HAVE A SUPPORTING CONCERT
FROM THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION KATHY
SANDERLING ALL WE GET A WORKED
AND MET WITH THE AUTHOR STAFF
WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL
WE'VE BEEN VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
AS OBVIOUSLY EVERYONE ELSE HAS
BEEN.
WE JUST WANT TO SORT OF MAKE
SURE FOLKS AT THE TABLE AND
TALKING TO OUR APPROPRIATE ROLE
IN CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES VIS A
VIS THE STATE AND THE CITY SOME
OF OUR COUNTY PARTNERS.
IN THE OTHER AGENCIES SUCH AS
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH OR PUBLIC
HEALTH THERE MAY BE SOME OTHER
FOLKS TO KIND OF PULL THE TABLE
AND KIND OF SORT EVERYTHING OUT
WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WILL HAPPEN
WHICH IS WHY WERE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE BILL AND HOPE IT MOVES
FORWARD TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND NOW IN THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SAYING NONE.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
WAS GONNA SAY I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD I THINK WE ALL HAVE SEEN
THE HORRORS.
AND DO WE FELT HELPLESS BECAUSE
WE ARE AT THE STATE NOT AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
AND FELT THAT EVERYTHING COULD
ONLY BE LOOKED AT AND DEALT WITH
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
CREATIVE IN THIS.
I DO THINK THE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE HARD WORK THEY PUT.
IN INTO THIS BILL TO BE -- TO
BRING IT TO THE POINT WHERE IT
IS NOW TO BE ABLE TO MOVE IT
FORWARD -- WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MS FRIEDMAN SECOND BY MISS
RIVERS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES AND I WALK ON THE EXPERTS TO
THE TABLE LIKE I SAID I'M I'M
NOT AN EXPERT IN THE SPACE AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET IT US
RIGHT AS POSSIBLE.
AND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE UP
ALL OF YOUR WORK -- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON THIS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU PLEASE TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RAMOS HI RES I MATHIS
[inaudible]
REVERSE [inaudible]
REVERSE ON CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE.
STONE AYE.
YOUR FOR TWO ZERO WILL LEAVE THE
RECORD OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
OKAY AND FILE ORDER WE HAVE A
DOCTOR QUIRK.
ON ITEM SIXTEEN AB.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU
CHAIR IN MEMBERS.
THANKS ALSO TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THEIR COMMENTS.
OUR WORK WITH MY STAFF TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL OF THOSE CONCERNS
YOU'RE DRESSED.
AND WORK WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS -- BOTH THOSE WHO.
RUN THE COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
THOSE IN THE COMMUNITIES AS WELL
AS THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES.
AND WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND WILL.
I BELIEVE MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
CONSENSUS BELL.
A CONTINUING CARE RETIREMENT
COMMUNITIES ARE UNIQUE IN THAT
THEY PROVIDE INDEPENDENT LIVING.
ASSISTED LIVING AND SKILLED
NURSING HOME AND OPTIONS SO THAT
SENIORS MAY MOVE FORWARD BETWEEN
INDEPENDENCE. TO HIGH LEVELS OF
CARE WITHOUT LEAVING THE
COMMUNITY. TO SECURE THIS PEACE
OF MIND RESIDENTS PAY AN
ENTRANCE FEE IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
AS WELL AS AN ON GOING MONTHLY
FEE I SHOULD KNOW I LIVE IN ONE
OF THESE COMMUNITIES I'M THE
YOUNG GUY -- AND ONCE YOU PAY
THAT ENTRANCE FEE YOU REALLY ARE
STOCK.
IF THERE'S A FINANCIAL PROBLEM.
AND THIS BILL -- JUST DEALS WITH
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY TO ABLE
TO UNDERSTAND IF THERE ARE
FINANCIAL PROBLEMS -- THESE ARE
OFTEN VERY.
I'LL SPEAK FOR MY OWN COMMUNITY
HIGHLY HIGHLY TALENTED
INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN LAWYERS
AND DOCTORS AND SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS.
THEY REALLY CAN.
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON AND
AND IN ANY WAY THEY CAN HELP.
SO ABC.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY NINE WOULD
INCREASE THE FINANCIAL
TRANSPARENCY OF CONTINUING CARE
RETIREMENT COMMUNITIES.
AND ALERTS THE DEPARTMENT TO
SIGNS OF FINANCIAL STRESS.
SO THEY CAN TAKE ACTION BEFORE
THE FUTURE THE COMMUNITY IS
COMPROMISED.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE IS MARGARET
GRIFFITH -- PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONTINUING CARE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY.
I MARKET DRIVEN PRESIDENT CAL
CROW CALIFORNIA CONTINUING CARE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION AND A
RESIDENT OF UNIVERSITY
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY.
A C. C. R. C. IN DAVIS.
ALSO ONE OF THE ON ONCE.
MY HUSBAND AND I MOVED TO OUR C.
C. R. C. FOURTEEN YEARS AGO I'VE
BEEN ON THE CALPERS BOARD SINCE
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND PRESIDENT
SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND TEN C. C. R. C.
PROVIDERS PROMISED BENEFITS. FOR
UP FRONT DEPOSITS AND PERIODIC
PAYMENTS MADE BY RESIDENTS.
AS YOU MIGHT IMAGINE AS OUR
AUTHOR STATED WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN THE FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
THE CONTINUING CARE BRANCH OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
MONITORING THE FINANCIAL
CONDITION OF C. C. R. C.
PROVIDERS.
THIS OVERSIGHT IS PRIMARILY
CONDUCTED.
THROUGH REVIEW OF THE PROVIDERS
ANNUAL REPORTS WHICH ARE
COMPRISED OF AUDITED FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS AND RELATED DATA.
SHOULD DSS SEE INDICATIONS OF C.
C. R. C. MAY BE IN FINANCIAL
DIFFICULTY.
THE BRANCH MAY REQUIRE A
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY NINE WOULD
ESTABLISH SPECIFIC CRITERIA THE
BRANCH COULD USE IN ANALYZING A
PROVIDERS CURRENT FINANCIAL
SITUATION.
AND IT WOULD REQUIRE THAT ANY
RESULTING CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN
AND RELATED PROGRESS REPORTS.
BE SHARED WITH THE RESIDENTS
COUNCIL OF THE C. C. R. C..
UNLIKELY PERSPECTIVE RESIDENTS.
CURRENTLY I HAVE NO WAY OF
KNOWING.
IF DSS HAS DETERMINED THAT MY C.
C. R. C. IS ON SHAKY GROUND WHEN
IT COMES TO FINANCIAL SOLVENCY.
NOR DO I KNOW IF DSS IS EVEN
AWARE OF SUCH A SITUATION WHERE
IT'S TAKEN ANY ACTION IN THAT
REGARD.
AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY NINE
ESTABLISHES AN EARLY
INTERVENTION SYSTEM BASED ON THE
C. C. R. C.'S CURRENT
PERFORMANCE. TO IDENTIFY.
MEDICAID.
OR RESOLVE FINANCIAL ISSUES SO
THAT A PROVIDER MAY AVOID
INSOLVENCY IN BANKRUPTCY.
THIS IS WHY AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
NINE IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO SEE
SEE OUR RESIDENTS I OR TRY TO
VOTE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT WITH THIS IS IN
OPPOSITION.
WE'RE ACTUALLY NEITHER IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WERE
COMING UP WORKING TOWARD SUPPORT --
PETER CALLISON ON BEHALF OF
LEADING AIDS CALIFORNIA WHICH
REPRESENTS THE NOT FOR PROFIT
CCRC.
MEMBERS IN THE STATE.
WE APPRECIATE THE DIRECTION THE
AUTHORS GOING WE AGREE ON THE
GENERAL GOAL WE THINK THAT THERE
ARE SOME ELEMENTS OF THE
TECHNICAL DETAILS THAT ARE NOT
QUITE.
FINISHED YET AND WE ARE IT INTO
IS THE ASPECT TO CONTINUE
pWORKING WITH THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN
VERY RESPONSIVE.
AS AS A STAFF AND COMMITTEE
STAFF AND THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE DISCUSSION STAKEHOLDERS.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN DEAL WITH
OCCUPANCY RATE TRIGGERS OTHER
THINGS TO GET TO A FINAL PLACE
WHERE WE THINK THE BILL IS
COMPLETELY WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE.
THANK YOU.
VERY BRIEFLY HEATHER HARRISON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
LIVING ASSOCIATION ALSO
SUPPORTIVE OF THE CONCEPT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL AND LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING MEAN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSOR.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION IN BETWEEN.
ALL RIGHT SAYING NONE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SAYING NONE OF DR QUIRK WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SB ARRIVE VOTE.
RIGHT WE HAVE EIGHT OF THEM THE
BILL WAS MOVED BY MISTREATMENT
SECOND BY MS REAVIS PLEASE TAKE
THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I AM
MATHIS.
MATHIS I REVERSE.
REVERSE I CHOI.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE.
STONE AYE.
THE BILL VOTE IS SIX ZERO THE
BILLS UP BELIEVE THAT -- ROL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT IN SIGN IN ORDER
[inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
MR FRAZIER [inaudible]
YEAH BECAUSE THE BILL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE ONE BILL
THAT WAS.
IN SPECIAL ORDER BECAUSE OF HOW
IT'S DOUBLE REFERRED AND THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WICKS WOULD YOU
PLEASE.
TAKE ROLE OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE THE
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO ONE CHOI
[inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON I MAIENSCHEIN STONE.
STONE I'D CURRENT VOTE.
I'M SORRY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
CURRENT SEVEN TO ZERO I'M SORRY.
SEVEN ONE ALL RIGHT SEVEN TO ONE
THAT BILL IS OUT AND POST WE
DIDN'T HAVE FOUR SEVEN ZERO
SORRY CURRENT VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO ALL RIGHT THAT
BILL IS OUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MR FRAZIER ON YOUR FIRST BILL.
ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE THREE SIX VERY
GOOD.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB FIVE THIRTY SIX
EXTENDS THE AGE OF ONSET THE
DEFINITION FROM EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD. TWENTY TWO
YEARS OF AGE SO WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN IN REAL LIFE TERMS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ANYONE WHO
OBTAINS A DEVELOPMENTAL DISS
DISABILITY AFTER AGE EIGHTEEN IS
PRECLUDED.
FROM UTILIZATION UTILIZING THE
REGIONAL CENTERS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THOSE
YOUNG ADULTS TO BENEFIT IMPROVE
FROM THOSE.
VERY IMPORTANT SERVICES.
THERE'S BEEN SHOWN THAT THOSE
WHO DO RECEIVE THESE SERVICES
BENEFIT GREATLY FROM.
THEM.
WITH IMPROVEMENTS IN BOTH
QUALITY OF LIFE AND
FUNCTIONALITY.
THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY BELIEVES
THAT THE BRAIN CONTINUES
DEVELOPMENT UNTIL AT LEAST
TWENTY TO MINE STILL IS.
AND HAS ONE MADE IT CLEAR THAT A
PERSON'S BRAIN.
HAS NOT COMPLETED ITS GROWTH
OVER DEVELOPMENT UNTIL THE AGE
OF TWENTY TWO AT LEAST INITIALLY.
AT LEAST INITIALLY THIRTY EIGHT
OTHER STATES HAVE DROPPED THE
BROADER AGE RANGE IN THEIR
DEFINITIONS OF DEVOUT ONE
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
SO IT MAKES SENSE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S ELIGIBILITY.
THRESHOLD TO MATCH FEDERAL
STANDARDS THIRTY EIGHT OTHER
STATES AND MORE IMPORTANTLY.
SCIENTIFIC DATA.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN THE
LEADER TO CHAMPION EFFORTS TO
INCREASE AND ENHANCE THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE WITH.
LIVING WITH ID DE.
AND THIS CHANGE IN LAW WOULD
HAVE A VERY SIGNIFICANT
MEANINGFUL IMPACT ON THE LIVES
OF THE STRUGGLING YOUNG DISABLED
CALIFORNIA.
WHO NEED OUR HELP?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME TODAY I'VE SENATOR
SCOTT WILK WHOSE BRAIN DID
DEVELOP BY.
TWENTY TWO ANOTHER GREAT
ADVOCATE FOR THE ID POPULATION
IN CITY SMITH FROM THE STATE
COUNCIL ON DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESSED PLACE.
YET THANK YOU FOR SO PROVIDE
WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP NOT ONLY ON THIS
ISSUE BUT ALL ISSUES FOR THIS
COMMUNITY THAT'S UNDER
REPRESENTATIVE AND OFTEN NOT
HURTS I WANT TO THANK YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE INCREDIBLE LEADER --
IVY COVERED ALL THE THE ONE
THING I WANT TO STRESS IS THAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CHANGE
THEIR STANDARDS FORTY FORTY
YEARS AGO.
AND WE'VE YET TO DO IT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE
TACKLE AS A LEGISLATURE WHEN IT
COMES -- TO JUVENILE JUSTICE
SOCIAL JUSTICE WE'VE CHANGED A
LOT OF THE LAS BECAUSE WE KNOW
THAT THE BRAIN HASN'T YET BEEN
DEVELOPED AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE YET WE DON'T DO IT
HERE.
THIS ISSUE FIRST CAME TO ME AT A
YOUNG MAN IN MY DISTRICT SIX
WEEKS AFTER HE TURNED EIGHTEEN
HE WAS T. BONED BY TRUCK --
DRUNK DRIVER IN SUFFERED TRAN --
TRAUMA TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY
AND WAS UNABLE TO ACCESS
SERVICES NOW HE'S FORTUNATE HIS
FATHER'S A VERY SUCCESSFUL
SCREENWRITER.
AND SO THE COSTS A LOT OF MONEY
HE WAS ABLE TO GET THOSE
SERVICES AND HE'S.
DONE REMARKABLY WELL NOT WHERE
HE WAS BUT REMARKABLY WELL BUT
THERE'S TOO MANY PEOPLE OUT
THERE WHERE THERE'S ACQUIRED OR
DRAMATIC.
THAT THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THAT AND THIS IS JUST YOU.
WE NEED TO LIFT UP ALL PEOPLE
AND THIS JUST THE RIGHTEOUS
THING TO DO AGAIN.
WOULD BE IN COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL FEDERAL LAW IN THIRTY
EIGHT OTHER STATES SO I AGAIN I
JOIN SENATOR -- CENTER HAVE BEEN
CUT PROMOTED.
SOME IN FRAZIER AND ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
HELLO CHAIR ASM FASTER MATHIS
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
AND CENTER WILL FOR CHAMPION
THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
MY NAME IS CINDY SMITH AND I AM
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR POLICY
AT THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES -- AS
THE PREVIOUS WITNESSES HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THE CITY COUNCIL
WAS CREATED CLOSE TO FIFTY YEARS
AGO AS PART OF THE FEDERAL
DEVELOPMENT TO DISABILITIES AND
BILL OF RIGHTS ASSISTANCE ACT.
TO ADVOCATE FOR IMPROVEMENTS IN
THE SERVICE DELIVERY SYSTEM FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
CONGRESS CHANGED THE DEFINITION
DEVELOPMENTS DISABILITY FROM
USING A SPECIFIC LIST OF
CONDITIONS TO A MORE GENERALIZED
APPROACH FOCUSED ON FUNCTIONAL
LIMITATIONS.
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL WILL HAVE THE
DISABILITY FOR LIFE AND BE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED.
AT THE SAME TIME AS WAS ALREADY
STATED CONGRESS CHANGED THE AGE
OF ONSET REQUIRED TO HAVE A
DEVELOPMENT TO DISABILITY FROM.
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY TWO STE
THERE'S EVEN SOME STUDIES THAT
HAVE RECENTLY FOUND THAT BRING
DEVELOPMENT DOESN'T OCCUR UNTIL
THE TWENTY FIVE PEOPLE ARE STILL
DEVELOPING THEIR BRAINS -- IN A
DEVELOPMENT AS BILLY CAN OCCUR
AS A RESULT OF AN INJURY AND
ILLNESS OR GENETIC CONDITION.
FOR EXAMPLE AN INDIVIDUAL CAN
ACQUIRE A BRAIN INJURY FROM A
STROKE OR NEAR DROWNING.
A DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY FROM A
SPORTS INJURY OR ACCIDENT.
OR GENETIC OR THE HEALTH
CONDITION THAT DOESN'T DEVELOP
UNTIL LATER IN LIFE.
ENSURING THAT THESE PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO COMPREHENSIVE SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS SUCH AS THOSE
AVAILABLE IN THE REGIONAL
CENTERS IS CRITICAL. TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE ARE REQUIRED THE
DISABILITY AND AND LATER IN LIFE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
LEARN HOW TO THEY'RE GOING TO
ADJUST TO LIFE WITH A
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITY PROBABLY
FOR THE REMAINDER OF THEIR LIFE.
THE COUNCIL BELIEVES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE THE STATUTORY
CHANGE DEFINITION TO MORE
CLOSELY ALIGN THE STATE
DEFINITION WITH THE FEDERAL
DEFINITION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE AND I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ERIC HARRIS WITH OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
EACH EACH WITH.
MADAM MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
RICKROLLING TRIPS AS AN
ARCHITECT SO SHE SHOULD REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES SO.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
SENATOR WELL CAN PASSED ON THIS
LEGISLATION AND OUR POSITION
TODAY ON THE BILL AS WITH CENTER
WORKS LEGISLATION WAS SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED.
WE ARE CONCERNED OF COURSE ABOUT
FUNDING FOR OUR SYSTEM IN THERE
TOO I AM VERY IMPORTANT --
ISSUES FACING OUR SYSTEM OF THE
MEDIAN RATE -- THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED -- THAT HAS BEEN A
REAL CURSE QUITE FRANKLY IN
GETTING PROVIDERS AND OUR
COMMUNITY AND ALSO THE FREEZE ON
NEW PROGRAM DEVELOPMENT.
AND ALTHOUGH OUR SYSTEM SERS
PRIMARILY PEOPLE ISSUE NOW WITH
AUTISM CEREBRAL PALSY EPILEPSY
AND INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
RAISING THE AGE AND ALSO ON
EXPANDING THE ELIGIBILITY TO
OTHERS OUTSIDE OF THAT GROUP
WILL.
REQUIRE THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW
PROGRAMS AND THAT'S WHY WE WHICH
SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT WE IT'S
CONDITIONAL QUITE FRANKLY ON
GETTING RID OF THE MEDIAN RATES
AND THE FREEZE ON NEW PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF MEMBERS
CARL LUNDEN HERE ABOUT THE
ALLIANCE SUPPORTING PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENT
DISABILITIES WE UNEQUIVOCALLY
SPORT BILL THANK CENTER WOKEN.
MISTER FRAZIER FOR THEIR EFFORTS
ON THIS THANK YOU.
MARILYN LAMPI OF EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF GENESIS THAT WERE
PART OF A GROUP OF GROUPS CALLED
KAMALA OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND ALISON RANTS REPRESENTING
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED -- THIS
BILL IS MEDICALLY LEGALLY AND
ETHICALLY THE RIGHT THING TO DO
AND WE COULD NOT SUPPORT MORE
STRONGLY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME'S ANA ACT IN
WITH READ CENTER FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING AND ONE OF SEVEN
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY PROGRAM
SITES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA --
WE WORK WITH INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE PART OF THE BRAIN INJURY CAN
THINK IT TO INDIVIDUALS THAT
GETS GOT SIGNIFICANT DRAMATIC
BRAIN INJURIES.
BEFORE THE AGE OF TWENTY TWO BUT
AFTER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN AT
THAT COULD GREATLY BENEFIT FROM
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICES THOSE
THE TYPE OF SERVICES INDIVIDUALS
NEED.
ARE THE SEVEN DRAMATIC BRAIN
INJURY PROGRAM SITES ARE WORKING
ON VERY LIMITED RESOURCES AND
HAVING ACCESS TO THESE SERVICES
WOULD BE PHENOMENAL FOR
INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO NATALIE COOPER FROM
FAMILIES FOR EARLY AUTISM
TREATMENT IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE RIVER MOLLY HAWES AB
REPRESENTING KAMALA CALIFORNIA
AND GENESIS OF THE TRI VALLEY.
IN SUPPORT OF THE SPELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I'M TERRY MEMBERS THERESA
ANDERSON WITH THE ARE CAN YOU
SEE P. CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR VERY
JUTTING CALIFORNIA DISABILITY
SERVICES ASSOCIATION WE HAVEN'T
TAKEN A FORMAL POSITION YET
ALTHOUGH I THINK -- WE KNOW THAT
THIS VEHICLE RIGHT DECISION --
OUR CONCERNS I THINK AT THIS
POINT WHAT WE WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR -- IS SIMILAR TO
WHAT ARE COULD RELATE ABOUT
CAPACITY OUR MEMBERS ARE WORRIED
ABOUT WAIT LIST THAT THEY
ALREADY HAVE AND MAKING SURE
THAT THERE'S AN ADEQUATE
CAPACITY FOR URBAN AND HE'S THE
SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
MR FRAZIER AYE I THINK THAT IT
IS CLEAR THAT TO EVERYBODY
AGREES THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT.
IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
I I DO APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM ARCA OFFER MR ROLLINS
REGARDING THE FACT THAT.
WE ARE FINITE RESOURCES AND IF
WE HAVE PEOPLE WAITING TO GET
THOSE SERVICES WE EXPAND IT.
THEN THE NEXT THING IS WE DO
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
INCREASE THE FUNDING AS WELL.
SO I KNOW THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK ON A
SENATOR AYE THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY -- WE HAVE
A MOTION.
WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION SO I'D
LIKE TO ENTER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PROMOTION SECOND
PLEASE TAKE.
A WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
PLEASE.
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK
CENTER WILL CORPS INCLUDING ME
HE'S BEEN IN A PASSIONATE
CHAMPION.
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS TRYING TO
GET THIS.
WONDERFUL IDEA PAST MY
DAUGHTER'S OWNER OF A NEURO
PSYCHOLOGIST AND AND RUNS ACROSS
THIS ALL THE TIME IN SHORT
MEMORIAL HOSPITAL SAN DIEGO.
THIS WILL ALSO INCLUDE VETERANS.
WHO ARE WHO HAVE DRAMATIC BRAIN
INJURY WHO SERVED OUR COUNTRY?
AND WILL BE ABLE TO GET THEM THE
THE HELP THAT THEY DESERVE.
GOING FORWARD -- ONE OF THE
THINGS WE TALK ABOUT IS IN THE
CONCERNS OF SOME OF THE THE THE
FUNDING.
SET UP ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
I HAVE THE THREE HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION DOLLAR BRIDGE
FUNDING BILL.
PASSED THROUGH -- THE THE
COMMITTEE SAYS AS YET SO WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THE RATE STUDY SAID THAT
THERE WAS A ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLAR.
DEFICIENCY IN FUNDING FOR THE ID
DEPOPULATION THROUGH DDS.
MY COMMITMENT IS TO WORK THROUGH
THAT FINDING A REVENUE SOURCE
MAKING SURE THAT THE UNDERSERVED
SERVED.
I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW MUCH THIS
MEANS TO ME TO BE ABLE TO WORK
TOWARDS THIS PROCESS.
AND ALSO WORK WITH THIS
WONDERFUL MAN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE TAKE THE
ROLE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RANTS HI RAMOS AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS I REVERSE [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE CHOI.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE STONE AYE.
THE BILL OF PRESENT COUNTY IS
SIX TO ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE RECORD
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MANAGER.
HEY THE ERROR WE ALSO -- HAVE
YOU ON ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
EIGHT TWELVE MOVED BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FIRST I WILL PROBABLY EXCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS IS
REFERENCED IN THE ANALYSIS AND I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF. FOR DOING A WONDERFUL
ANALYSIS AND THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS
ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AB EIGHT TWELVE WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO CONVENE A
COMPREHENSIVE WORK GROUP TO
EXAMINE ENSURE THE EFFICACY.
OF THE CURRENT OVERSIGHT OF THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES SYSTEM.
THIS WORKGROUP WILL BE REQUIRED
TO SUBMIT A REPORT NO LATER THAN
JANUARY FIRST. TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE TO THE LEGISLATURE
HIGHLIGHTING THE DO PREVENTIVE
SERVICES THE EXISTING OVERSIGHT
ROLES INSTRUCTORS.
AND THEY ALSO IN A AND IDENTIFY
ANY GAPS OR INCONSISTENCIES THAT
EXIST WITHIN CURRENT OVERSIGHT
ROLES IN STRUCTURES.
MEMBERS THE ID THE POPULATION IS
ONE OF THE MOST OVERLOOKED.
UNDERSERVED MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA.
I AM CONCERNED AT THE COMPLEXITY
OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL.
THE NOBEL THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SYSTEM AND REGIONAL
CENTERS SERVICE PROVISION HAS
BEEN OVERLOOKED AND NOT
ADEQUATELY OVERSEEN.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE REPORT
THAT WILL BE GENERATED FOR THIS
WORKGROUP.
WILL BE READY TO INTRODUCE ANY
LEGISLATION.
THAT FIXES NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THAT MOST ARE VULNERABLE.
CALIFORNIANS RECEIVE THE
SERVICES OF SUPPORT THAT THEY
NEED AND DESERVE.
I THINK THAT WE CAN GO TO THE
AUDIT THAT WAS PERFORMED
RECENTLY BY THE STATE OR ON THE
ON THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT CAN
BE DONE WELL AND BETTER.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT THEY'RE NOT
TRYING BUT I THINK THAT THERE WE
GET IN RUTS AND I THINK THAT
SOMEBODY FROM THE FROM THE
OUTSIDE CAN ACTUALLY GIVE.
A BETTER PERSPECTIVE ON HOW WE
CAN DO THINGS BETTER -- WE ALSO
WILL LOOK AT WHEN WE DID SB ONE
THE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING THAT
I'M SO PROUD OF WE ALSO HAD AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT WAS
INSTALLED IN THE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
CALTRANS.
FOUND HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF SAVINGS.
AND FRAUD AND OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TAXPAYERS MONEY.
ARE GETTING THE BEST VALUE THAT
WE CAN.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR WHO I KNOW IS
PASSIONATE ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT.
THE THE THE GROUP THAT WE ARE SO.
COMMONLY -- INEFFECTUAL
CONCERNED ABOUT.
OF THAT WE CAN WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS GOES FORWARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME TODAY.
NATALIE COOPER FROM FAMILIES FOR
EARLY AUTISM TREATMENT AND
ALISON BRANDT. FOR DISABILITIES
VOICES UNITED WHO HAVE BEEN AT
MANY OF OUR MEETINGS AND MANY OF
OUR ADVOCACY COMPONENTS PLEASE
WONDERFUL FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NATALIE
COOPER I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF
FAMILIES. FOR EARLY AUTISM
TREATMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB.
EIGHT ONE TWO FEET WAS FOUNDED
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO AND A
SERVE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES FREE
OF CHARGE OF PROVIDING EDUCATION
ADVOCACY AND INTERVENTION
SUPPORT.
IN MY OWN EXPERIENCE AS A PARENT
OF A SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD I HAVE
BEEN.
REQUIRED TO STRONGLY ADVOCATE
YEAR AFTER YEAR TO EXCESS
SEVERAL ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
THESE HAVE BEEN SOME OF THE MOST
DIFFICULT PAINFUL EXPERIENCES OF
MY LIFE.
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LOAN
[inaudible] THREE UP AGAINST
THE VERY LARGE AGENCY TRYING TO
SECURE THE SERVICES MY FOR
HONORABLE SET NEEDED.
AT THE SAME TIME CARING FOR HIS
INTENSIVE NEEDS.
AB EIGHT ONE TWO WAS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR FAMILIES RECEIVE THE
SERVICES AND SUPPORTS WITH IN
THIS A VERY COMPLEX
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY SYSTEM
AND OF SERVICES.
THE TWENTY ONE REGIONAL CENTERS
AUTHORIZED BY THAT LETTERMAN
ACTS DO NOT OPERATE UNIFORMLY
NOR WITH TRANSPARENCY. FOR
INSTANCE WHY IS IT THAT SOME
FAMILIES ARE OFFERED RESPITE
WITH MAXIMAL HOURS WELL OTHER
FAMILIES.
ARE CHALLENGED AND OFFER WITH
CHALLENGES ARE OFFERED LITTLE TO
NONE.
WHY DOES IT TAKE DUE PROCESS
HEARINGS TOP THE SAME ISSUE THAT
WAS DECIDED BY A JUDGE IN THE
FAVOR OF THE CONSUMER LAST
CALENDAR YEAR [inaudible]
PROVIDE. TO GET A PROVIDED IN
THE NEXT CALENDAR YEAR WHY SO
OFTEN WHEN FAMILIES ARE IN
CRISIS AND TURN TO THE VERY
AGENCY THAT EXISTS AND IS FUNDED
TO HELP THEM.
ARE LEFT UNSUPPORTED AND FEELING
EVEN MORE DISCOURAGED.
WE BELIEVE THAT INSPECTOR
GENERAL WITH EXCLUSIVE FOCUS ON
THE REGIONAL CENTERS WOULD
IMPROVE THE QUALITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS OF SERVICES AND
WOULD BRING ACCOUNTABILITY TO
THE OPERATION SERVICE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS.
THE WORKER PROPOSED AN AB EIGHT
TWELVE WILL MOVE THE CAN.
CONVERSATION FOR AND AND SHOW
THAT FOR TOO LONG.
WAY TOO LONG REGIONAL CENTERS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO OPERATE WITH
LITTLE OVERSIGHT AND NO REAL
TRANSPARENCY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS ALLISON RANTS ON THE
MOTHER OF A THIRTEEN YEAR OLD
BOY SIR BY SAN ANDREAS REGIONAL
CENTER AND ALSO A LAW PROFESSOR
AT STANFORD -- BUT I'M HERE
TODAY AS A BOARD MEMBER OF
DISABILITY VOICES UNITED -- O
DO TWO THINGS FIRST I WANT TO
CONVEY THE SCOPE OF THE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
PROBLEM.
AS WE JUST HEARD TESTIMONY.
RIDLEY THAT WE'RE FACING SO YOU
UNDERSTAND WHY WE NEED A BILL OF
THIS KIND AND SECONDLY I WANT TO
EXPLAIN WHY WE THINK AB EIGHT
TWELVE IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
SO SO THE COMPLICATED
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN DDS AND THE
TWENTY ONE PRIVATE NON PROFIT
SAID OVERSEAS WHICH IS UNIQUE IN
THE COUNTRY THERE'S NO OTHER
STATE THAT HAS THIS COMPLICATED
CONFIGURATION.
MAKES ACCOUNTABILITY
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING AND THE
WAY THAT THIS RELATIONSHIP HAS
UNFOLDED OVER THE PAST HALF
CENTURY HAS LEAD TO CHRONIC AN
OFTEN QUITE DRAMATIC AS WE'VE
HEARD SHORTFALLS IN OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS IS NO SECRET BOTH THE STATE
AUDITOR AND THE STATE
COMPTROLLER HAVE HIGHLIGHTED THE
SHORTFALLS IN REPORTS THAT
STRETCH BACK FOR DECADES AS
EARLY AS NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
THE STATE AUDITOR -- ISSUED A
REPORT HIGHLIGHTING THE FAILURE
OF THE DEPARTMENT TO HOLD
REGIONAL CENTERS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
DISPARITIES ACROSS REGIONAL
CENTERS IN THE RECEIPT OF
SERVICES A COULD NOT BE
JUSTIFIED BY DIFFERENCES AND
THEY'RE THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
SERVE.
AS RECENTLY TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE STATE COMPTROLLER TOUCH AND
VERY SIMILAR THEMES IN ITS
EVALUATION OF DD **** ON THE
REGIONAL CENTERS USE OF STATE
FUNDS -- WITH REGARD TO
COMPLIANCE WITH FEDERAL AND
AUDITING STANDARDS AND FINANCIAL
CONTROLS OR LACK THERE OF IN
RESPONSE TO WITH THE BLUR
COMPLAINTS.
BUT YOU MIGHT WONDER WHAT DOES
ALL THIS MEAN IN PRACTICE FOR
CONSUMERS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WELL FIRST OF ALL -- IT MEANS
FOR EXAMPLE THAT THE SELF
DETERMINATION LAW WITH WHICH IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A
FIVE AND A HALF YEARS AGO.
AFTER A LONG SERIES OF DELAYS AS
I SEE HERE TODAY STILL HAS NOT
BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
IT MEANS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS SPENT THIRTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE PAST THREE YEARS.
ON IN ORDER TO COMBAT ONGOING
RACIAL AND ETHNIC INEQUALITIES
IN OUR SYSTEM AND OVERTHE PAST
THREE YEARS.
THE DISPARITIES BETWEEN WHITES
AND LATINOS THE TWO LARGEST
GROUP SERVE BY THE SYSTEM HAVE
ACTUALLY GOTTEN BIGGER RATHER
THAN SMALLER AFTER THE
EXPENDITURES OF OF THOSE THAT
THIRTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
ON THE SHORTFALL IN OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY ALSO MEANS
THAT WE HAVE NOT YET BUILT A
SAFETY NET TO SUPPORT FAMILIES
AND CONSUMERS WITH SIGNIFICANT
BEHAVIORAL AND HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
SO THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT GETTING
HELP THAT THEY NEED WHEN THEY
NEED IT.
SO NOW THAT I'VE BRIEFLY ALLUDED
TO THE NATURE OF THE PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE FACING.
THERE'S TWO SIMPLE REASONS WHY
WE FEEL THAT AB EIGHT TWELVE A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
SO FIRST IT TRIES TO PUT THE
GOAL OF OF ADDRESSING SHORTFALLS
IN OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FRONT AND CENTER.
SECONDLY IT BRINGS TOGETHER A
NUMBER OF KEY STAKEHOLDERS.
DDS REGIONAL CENTERS DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL
STATE HONOR AND STATE CONTROLLER
TO DISCUSS THE SCOPE OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PROBLEM AND MAKE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS ABOUT HOW
TO FIX IT.
NOW WE'D TV YOU DO HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS AND SUGGESTIONS ABOUT
HOW TO FLESH OUT THE DETAILS OF
THIS BILL AND MAKE IT STRONGER.
THAT WE VERY MUCH HOPE THE THE
AUTHOR CONSIDER BUT TO SUM UP WE
COULD NOT AGREE MORE WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER -- ON THE
NEED TO ADDRESS THE LONGSTANDING
SHORTFALL IN THE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OUR SYSTEM AND WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL FOR HIM FOR
TAKING SUCH STRONG LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE WHICH IS SO BADLY
NEEDED.
WE THINK THAT AB EIGHT TWELVE IS
A CRITICAL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS -- TO FLUSH
IT OUT AND STRENGTHEN IT WHILE
HELPING TO PUSH IT FORWARD THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MARILYN LAMBIE AGAIN WITH
GENESIS A CAMELLIA OF CALIFORNIA
WE'RE IN SUPPORT AS LONG AS THE
WORKING GROUP INCLUDES SOMEONE
WHO REPRESENTS OR AT IS AT LEAST
SPANISH SPEAKING ABOUT IS JUST
SOMETHING IS.
THESE GROUPS LEAN WHITE OFTEN AT
THE TOP AND WE JUST THINK THAT
THAT IS A REALLY BIG LIKE
GLARING HOLE IN THE WAY THAT THE
SERVICES ARE GIVE IT.
VENTURE MEMBERS CARLIN AND AGAIN
HERE ABOUT THAT LINE SUPPORTING
PEOPLE BY DD IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
RIVER MOLLY HOUSE REPRESENTING
CAMELLIA ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND
GENESIS OF THE TRI VALLEY
STANDING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
YES MISS RIOS.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRAZIR -- FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND AND I
WANNA THANK ON MUTE FOR SHARING
YOUR STORIES YOU KNOW OVER THE
PAST FEW MONTHS I'VE MET WITH
CONSTITUENTS IN MY DISTRICT ARE
CONSUMERS OF REGIONAL CENTERS
AND FEEL THEY'VE SHARED STORIES
SIMILAR TO YOURS WHERE THE
CONCERNS ABOUT.
OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND QUALITY
AND EFFECTIVENESS SERVICES --
AND JUST THE THE CONFUSION --
YOU KNOW THEY ALL SHARE THE
PASSION OF JUST HELPING THEIR
CHILDREN RIGHT IN -- IN SO I'M.
I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL I LOOK FORWARD -- TO THE
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS THAT
YOU'VE MENTIONED IN TERMS OF
MAKING THIS AN EFFECTIVE
WORKGROUP THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MS RIVAS MR
MAIENSCHEIN.
THANK YOU AND I JUST WANT TO
BRIEFLY SAY I COMMEND YOU MISTER
FRAZIER FOR YOU YOUR PASSION ON
THIS ISSUE.
THIS ONE AND THE COUNT REALLY
THE IMAGE THE CAN DOWN TODAY BUT
REALLY ALL THE DAYS THAT YOU'VE
WORKED ON THIS - AND BEEN A
VOICE FOR THIS POPULATION THAT
SO NECESSARY AND YOU KEEP
PUSHING ON AT I KNOW IT'S
PERSONALLY IMPORTANTE MEANS A
LOT TO YOU BUT BUT I WANT TO SAY
THE COLLECTIVE IMPACT OF THIS IS
IS SIGNIFICANT SO I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU.
THE THESE ARE THIS IMPORTANT
BILL HAPPY IS FOR IT MA'AM THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY -- I'VE
WORKED WITH A FOR FOR MANY YEARS
I WITH REGIONAL CENTER MY
DISTRICT I KNOW IT CAN BE.
I KNOW.
HOW CUMPLIR IN EFFECT MYSTERY
MAVERICK AND HAVING A BRIEF
DISCUSSION TO ABOUT HOW JUST
COMPLICATED IT CAN BE AN?
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE ALREADY
CARRYING -- YOU KNOW CARING FOR
A CHILD -- AND SOMETIMES I THINK
PEOPLE -- INFAMOUS I'M A SINGLE
DAD AND THERE'S A LOT OF
INSENSITIVITY TO WHAT THAT
ENTAILS IN TERMS OF EVEN OUR
ASSEMBLY SCHEDULE OFTENTIMES --
HOW HARD IT IS TO TRY TO
NAVIGATE DRIVING ANALYSTS AT SO
SO I EMPATHIZE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DEAL WITH IN TERMS OF
THE CARE FOR CHAU?
PLUS ALL THE OTHER ISSUES THAT
ARE REALLY THRUST UPON YOU AND
THE FRUSTRATION THAT I KNOW YOU
OFTENTIMES GO THROUGH SO I THINK
THIS IS.
A BIG STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION -- AND AGAIN MR
FRAZIER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONTINUING TO BE THE VOICE IN
THE ASSEMBLY ON THIS TOPIC.
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS.
THE MANAGER.
OF THIS FRAZIER.
HI I KNOW.
AGAIN IT'S ALREADY BEEN SAID BUT
YOU REALLY ARE CHAMPION -- FOR
THIS COMMUNITY -- MA'AM ON A
FATHER OF TWO CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES -- ONE ON THE
AUTISTIC SPECTRUM AND ONE WITH.
SPINA BIFIDA SONG MAMA.
REGIONAL CENTER DAD SO I FEEL
YOU -- THE I'VE BEEN THERE AND
WE'VE SHED THOSE TEARS -- THE
HAVING IN.
INSPECTOR GENERAL THERE TO
REALLY LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT THINGS ARE HAPPENING ACROSS
THE BOARD THE WAY THEY SHOULD BE
IS DEFINITELY A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION CELL -- MISTER
FRAZIER ANYTHING I CAN DO TO
HELP ON ON THIS BILL -- COME ON
AS A CO OR WHATEVER YOU NEED
HE'S ON THERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
BUT I DO WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THERE'S NOT AN INSPECTOR GENERAL --
IT'S THE WORKING GROUP IT'LL BE
A WORKING GROUP AS AND MISTER
FRAZIER HAS ACCEPTED THAT THE
THE AMENDMENT SAYS AS NOTED
EARLIER.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I THANK YOU. FOR IT
JUST AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO BRING
YOUR TESTIMONY BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HEAR FROM.
FROM THOSE WHO HAVE GONE THROUGH
THE SYSTEM AND CAN TELL US
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE SYSTEM.
AND WHAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
MATHIS SECOND BY MS FRIEDMAN --
PLEASED WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE YES
JUST BRIEFLY MANAGER.
AS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABLED SELECT COMMITTEE IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'VE TRAVELED EXTENSIVELY
TALKING TO THE FAMILIES WITH OUR
WITH OUR OUR MEETINGS HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO DO SO.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA BE DOING A
TOTAL OF ELEVEN HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- IT'S OF
BENEFIT ONE'S GOING TO BE IN SAN
BERNADINO YES IT IS -- DULY
NOTED.
OF ONE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
HAS BEEN IS A PREVALENTTERM
THAT.
THEY FEEL THAT THERE'S NOT BEEN
ENOUGH TRANSPARENCY AND
OVERSIGHT.
DOESN'T MEAN THAT THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE DOING A JOB THEY ARE
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO
DISPARAGING.
I JUST THINK THAT SINCE I'VE
BEEN IN IN.
SINCE INCEPTION SINCENINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WE CAN DO SOME
THINGS BETTER AND I THINK WE GET
IN A RUT.
AND I THINK AN OUTSIDE PERSON AT
SOME POINT IN TIME CAN HELP US
DO THAT I WILL ALSO TELL YOU
THAT THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DDS
NANCY APARTMENT.
AS A ROCK STAR.
ABSOLUTELY ROCK STAR AND WOULD
NOT ABSOLUTELY -- IT'LL.
SHE HAS SO MANY IDEAS ASSEMBLY
PASSIONS BUT A LIMIT OF WHAT SHE
CAN DO.
BASED ON HER BUDGET.
IF WE CAN SAVE MONEY FOR HER
ALSO THROUGH THIS PROCESS WE
GAIN.
MORE VALUE.
AND SO I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
LOCAL WORKING TOWARDS THIS
PROCESS AND AGAIN.
THE MOST UNDERSERVED IN
OVERLOOKED POPULATION IN
CALIFORNIA THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THEY REALLY DO NEED THIS BODIES
HELP I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT LET'S TAKE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION DOES DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RAMOS
HI RES I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE REMUS.
REMUS I'D CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE STONE STONE AYE.
THE CURRENT COUNT IS. SIX TWO
ZERO THE BILL WILL GET OUT WE'RE
GOING TO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND SIGNED IN ORDER MS
WORKS.
ON ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B..
ONE ZERO TWO TWO I WOULD LIKE TO
REPORT TO YOU THAT THE SPECIAL
ORDER BILL -- DID RECEIVE THE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER AND HAS BEEN
SENT OVER.
TO COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT HUNGER
AGAIN.
WE'RE HERE TO TALK WE HAVE BEEN
HERE SINCE AN HOUR AGO SO.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP WORKING ON IT.
BUT I THINK I HAVE YET ONE MORE
ONE MORE BUT WE CAN START -- YES
PLEASE SO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- FOR ALLOWING ME
TO BE HERE TODAY I WANT TO
REALLY THANK THE COMMITTEE. FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS AND ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AT CAL FOR US IS THE STATE'S
MOST EFFECTIVE ANTI HUNGER
PROGRAM FOR MILLION CALIFORNIANS
CURRENTLY RECEIVE CAL FRESH
BENEFITS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX FEDERAL
WELFARE REFORM IMPLEMENTED
STRICT TIME LIMITS FOR ABLE
BODIED ADULTS WITHOUT DEPENDENCE.
OR IS THERE REFER TO IS A BONDS.
WHO RECEIVE SNAP BENEFITS?
THERE ARE ESTIMATED FIVE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE LIKELY
CLASSIFIED AS A BONDS.
THE USDA REPORTS THAT THE
INDIVIDUALS LIKELY TO BE CUT OFF --
BY THE A BY TIME LIMIT HAVE AN
AVERAGE MONTHLY INCOME OF
APPROXIMATELY 17% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL.
AND QUALIFY FOR NO OTHER INCOME
SUPPORT.
THIS POPULATION OF LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDES PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
FORMER FOSTER CARE A YOUTH --
FROM A FOSTER CARE YOUTH
INDIVIDUALS THAT INDIVIDUAL
DISABILITIES AND FAMILY CARE
GIVERS AND THE IMPACT ON THE
LOSS OF CALIFORNIA ELIGIBILITY.
DEPENDS CURRENT INEQUITIES -- MY
BILL AB TEN TWENTY TWO PROMOTES
EMPLOYMENT AND PROVIDES BENEFITS
TO PREVENT HUNGER BY
ESTABLISHING THE CALIFORNIA ANTI
HUNGER RESPONSE AND EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING.
PROGRAM.
CHARACTERS WERE REFERRING TO IT
THIS PROGRAM WILL PROVIDE
BENEFITS TO INDIVIDUALS WHO LOSE
ELIGIBILITY FOR FEDERALLY FUNDED
CAL FIRST DUE TO THE TIME LIMITS.
IT WILL ALSO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
CAL FIRST EMPLOYMENT AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT
WORK.
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
SUCH AS OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IMMIGRANTS AND SENIOR SUFFER
FROM HUNGER AND IS IMPORTANT WE
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY RESOURCES.
FOR THEM TO BE.
A WORK READY AND FOOD SECURE.
THIS IS ABOUT CREATING THE
OCIAL SAFETY NET I KNOW THAT
MANY OF US BELIEVE WE SHOULD
HAVE HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA VERTICALLY IN OUR
CURRENT.
ENVIRONMENT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
I WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS FOOD BANKS OF
CONTRA COSTA.
AND SOLANO ALAMEDA COUNTY FOOD
BANK AND THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
PROJECT USE THEMSELVES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN REYES
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BARRY BUT OFF OF A THIRTY YEAR
AT NINE YEAR OLD A WORK RESIDENT
ORIGINALLY FROM SANTA ROSA.
I HAVE HEALTH ISSUES THAT
PREVENT ME FROM BEING ABLE TO
WORK.
AT PTSD FROM EXPERIENCING TRAUMA
IN MY CHILDHOOD.
I GOT MY GED A TWENTY ONE
BECAUSE IT WAS IMPORTANT TO ME
BUT I BECAME ADDICTED TO HEROIN
AT AGE.
TWENTY THREE LRG ABSCISSA MY
HIPS IN MY EARLY TWENTIES WHICH
LEFT ME WITH SCIATIC I HAVE A
LARGE IN JANET'S CAR IN ON ANY
UNABLE TO SIT OR STAND FOR LONG
PERIODS OF TIME NOT YOUR PROBLEM
I KNOW.
I AM CURRENTLY TRYING TO GET SSI
GET ONE NINETY TWO A MONTH AND
CAL FRESH CUT PRETTY MUCH OF
ALWAYS BEEN HOMELESS OR COUCH
SURFING ANSWER RIDE BY GETTING
CAL FRESH.
IF I LOST MY CAL FISH MY ABILITY
HEALTHY WOULD BE EVEN MORE
CURTAIL THAN EVER BEFORE PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL MOREOVER IT'S
AN OUTRAGE IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
THEY DON'T GIVE US ENOUGH TODAY
DO NOT GIVEN UP GA OR FOOD
STAMPS.
THIS IS JUST ADDING ON TO
ANOTHER STACK OF BIBLES.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
HELLO MY NAME IS BUT THREE
SACRAMENTO AUGUST BE BUS -- I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY STORY I WORKED IN
CORPORATE AMERICA.
FOR MANY MANY YEARS TWENTY NINE
AND A HALF YEARS AND AFTER
TWENTY NINE AND A HALF YEARS I
WAS CORPORATE DOWNSIZED SO I
LOST MY JOB.
AND HAD A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
TRYING TO TRYING TO FIND A JOB --
WENT THROUGH UP ALL OF MY
SEVERANCE PAY WENT THROUGH MY
UNEMPLOYMENT WENT THROUGH MY
ENTIRE FOUR OH ONE K..
OKAY OUT SO I HAD TO IT RESULTED
IN ME HAVING TO GO ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE.
I TOOK TOOK ON CALPERS AND WAS
ABLE TO SURVIVE ON CALPERS.
LAW AND WHEN I THINK IN HERE
ABOUT WHAT.
WHAT THE LIMITS ARE ON PEOPLE
THAT ARE LOOKING FOR JOBS?
AND BY THE WAY WHEN I WAS
LOOKING FOR JOBS WENT THROUGH ET
DE AND WENT THROUGH ALL KINDS OF
TRAINING -- CLASSES SO I COULD
LEARN TO FIND MAYBE ANOTHER
ANOTHER POSITION EVEN WENT TO
THE FACT I WAS IN MANAGEMENT
WITH IN A LARGE CORPORATION.
AND I WENT THROUGH TRAINING
CLASSES FOR FORKLIFT DRIVING.
SO I CAN FIND A JOB.
OKAY AND THIS NINETY DAY RULE
THAT HAPPENS IS PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO BE OUT THERE.
NOT WORRYING ABOUT TRYING TO
FIND A JOB THEY'RE GOING TO
WORRY ABOUT HOW TO GET THEIR
NEXT MEAL.
SO WHAT HAPPENS WE CAN'T LET
THIS HAPPEN YOU KNOW WE I URGE
THAT WE PASS THIS BILL.
THANK YOU YOU WELCOME NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE -- I'M SORRY IT'S
JUST REALLY HARD TO HEAR ABOUT
PEOPLE GOING HUNGRY.
IN OUR STATE -- JUST SOMETHING
ONCE AND FIGHTING AGAINST THE
FEDERAL PROPOSALS TO MAKE IT
WORSE.
I'M SCARED THAT WE WON'T BE ABLE
[inaudible]
TO GIVEN BACK.
I'M REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE BILL
BE INTRODUCED DESPERATE FOR
WESTERN CENTER ON POVERTY.
MORE SPONSORED SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CHANTE
PRASAD I'M WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK.
WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL --
I WANTED TO READ.
TESTIMONY FROM MONICA CORONA WHO
COULD NOT BE HERE TODAY SHE HAD
PREPARED TESTIMONY WITH ME AND
IS UNFORTUNATELY IN THE HOSPITAL --
WHICH JUST UNDERSCORES -- HER
SITUATION AND HOW SHE WOULD.
NOT BE ABLE -- TO FIND A JOB IN
HER SITUATION.
SHE'S CURRENTLY ABBAS SOUTH
COUNTY HOMELESS PROJECT IN
HAYWARD.
A GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR REYES AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM MONICA CORONA.
I'VE LIVED IN HAYWARD SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND I'M
ORIGINALLY FROM.
LOS ANGELES I'M FORTY SIX AND
HAVE NO DEPENDENTS.
I DO HAVE THREE GROWN CHILDREN
THAT I RAISED ON MY OWN.
AGES TWENTY SIX TWENTY FOUR AND
EIGHTEEN AND TWO GRANDCHILDREN
WHO ARE THREE AND FOUR YEARS OLD
AND MY CHOI.
I HAVE ALWAYS WORKED MAINLY IN
WAREHOUSES OPERATING FORKLIFTS.
LAST DECEMBER I GOT REALLY
DEPRESSED AND WAS ADMITTED TO
JOHN GEORGE PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITAL
IN SAN LEANDRO I DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT HAPPENED TO ME BUT I
LOST MY JOB.
I HAVE EXPERIENCE CHILDHOOD
TRAUMA AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
IT MAY HAVE SOMETHING TO DO WITH
THAT.
I STAYED WITH MY UNCLE IN THE
PAST BUT HE COULDN'T HOUSE ME
ANY LONGER AND HAVE BEEN AT
SOUTH COUNTY HOMELESS PROJECT IN
HAYWARD. FOR THE PAST FEW MONTHS
MY CHILDREN ARE WORKING AND
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
THEY DON'T QUALIFY FOR COVERAGE --
BUT THEY ARE UNABLE TO HELP OUR
HOUSE ME.
THIS IS MY SECOND MONTH
RECEIVING CONFERENCE BENEFITS I
GET A HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO
DOLLARS A MONTH.
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL TO
PROTECT ME AND OTHERS IN MY
SITUATION WHO COULD LOSE THEIR
POWER FRESH BENEFITS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
CARLY SINGLE WITH THE FOOD BANK
OF CONTRA COSTA AND SOMEONE WHO
IS A CO SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND I'LL JUST
SHARE THAT -- WE DID -- HUNGER
STUDY LAST YEAR WE SURVEYED
HUNDREDS OF FOOD ASSISTANCE
RECIPIENTS ACROSS OUR TWO
COUNTIES AND FOUND THAT.
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE THAT WE
SERVE THAT ARE OF WORKING AGE
AND ABLE TO WORK ARE WORKING BUT
A THIRD OF THOSE PEOPLE ARE
WORKING LESS THAN TWENTY HOURS A
WEEK AND WOULD STILL BE SUBJECT
TO THESE TIME LIMITS UNDER THIS
RULE.
AND THEN AMONG THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE LOOKING FOR WORK THE
MAJORITY HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR
OVER THREE MONTHS AND I THINK IT
SPEAKS TO THAT THIS IS A REALLY
VULNERABLE.
POPULATION AND THAT MANY OF
THOSE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ARE RECEIVING CAO FRESH
FOOD ASSISTANCE AND STILL
NEEDING TO COME TO OUR FOOD BANK
DISTRIBUTIONS AND IT'S ONLY THE
TWO PROGRAMS IN COMBINATION THE
HELP MAKE ENDS MEET.
AND IF PEOPLE LOSE THEIR FOOD
ASSISTANCE THROUGH CAL FRESH OUR
PROGRAMS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEIR NUTRITIONAL NEEDS
ADEQUATELY CELL WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
BACK HERE SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS -- OUR
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTS FORTY
SOME FOOD BANKS ACROSS THE STATE
WHICH IN TURN -- PROVIDE
SERVICES THROUGH FOOD TO SIX
THOUSAND PLUS AGENCIES AROUND
THE STATE I'M AND I JUST WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT BUT I'M YOU KNOW AS
GRATEFUL AND AS WONDERFUL AS WE
ARE IT FOR A FEW DRINKS AND FOOD
PANTRIES AND ALL SORTS OF FREE
FOOD RESOURCES ACROSS THE STATE
BETTER THERE. FOR PEOPLE WHEN
THEY NEED IT THEY CERTAINLY
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO FILL THE GAP
SHOULD THIS ON REALLY HORRIFIC
RULE BE AFFECTING MORE PEOPLE
AND MAKING MAKING MORE PEOPLE
HUNGRY SO.
AND WE RE ARE REALLY ENDS STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS BILL AND THINK
THAT IT'S REALLY MUCH NEEDED
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SABINA PRESS SAID
HE WOULD LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PERSONS WITH CHILDREN AND WE ARE
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
STEPHEN SOMMERS I'M FROM OAKLAND
I'M A COMMUNITY VOLUNTEER
ADVOCATE WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK.
THAT'S A FORMAL A FORMERLY
HOMELESS PERSON WHO ONLY MADE IT
OUT OF THE SHELTER BY WORKING.
BY FINDING A JOB I UNDERSTAND
THE VALUE OF WORK -- AND THAT IS
WHY I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE
THOSE ROOF -- THIS BILL REFLECTS
MY VALUES HOWEVER.
I WAS ABLE TO FIND WORK.
ONLY WITH THE HELP OF CALIFORNIA.
SIMPLY PUT I DIDN'T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT WHERE MY NEXT MEAL
WAS COMING FROM.
AND I WE KNOW THAT WAS VERY
HELPFUL TO ME -- I WAS FREE TO
CONCENTRATE ON DOING THAT.
I REJECT THE ENTIRE CONCEPT IF
THEY BALK AT ANYWAY.
IT'S MEANT AS A SLUR THAT.
DEMONIZED AS THE POOR. TO QUOTE
FROM AN EXTERNAL AN EXCELLENT
ARTICLE.
IN THE NEW YORK TIMES CALLED.
WHO'S ABLE BODIED ANYWAY.
I'D LIKE TO QUOTE FROM THIS.
ABLE BODIED IS NOT TRULY.
A DEMOGRAPHIC LABEL.
THERE IS NO STANDARD FOR
PHYSICAL OR MENTAL ABILITY.
MAKES A PERSON ABLE.
RATHER.
THE TERM HAS LONG BEEN USED.
AS A POLITICAL.
THE ABLE BODIED COULD WORK.
BUT ARE NOT WORKING.
OR NOT WORKING HARD ENOUGH.
AND THEREFORE DON'T DESERVE OUR
HELP.
THE BARRIERS TO FINDING WORK.
FOR THIS POPULATION ARE REAL.
EVERYBODY I KNOW IN THE SAFETY
NET.
CAN WORK.
IS WORKING.
WORK RULES AND TIME LIMITS.
ARE ALSO INSIDIOUS.
BECAUSE ALL THEY DO.
PLEASE MAKE A PERSON WHO IS
ALREADY.
IN A STATE OF PANIC.
RUN OUT AND GET THE QUICKEST
EASIEST GIG THEY CAN GET.
IN ORDER TO JUST STAY ON THE
PROGRAM.
AND MANY OF THESE COMPANIES ARE
COMPLAINTS.
WALMART IS THE BIGGEST REDEEMER
OF FOOD STAMPS.
UNDER THE CURRENT.
RECENTLY PROPOSED SNAP CUTS.
THEY STAND TO LOSE. FIVE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER TEN YEARS.
AND THEY HAVE A VESTED INTEREST.
IN MAKING SURE PEOPLE STAY.
ON THE FOOD STAMP PROGRAM.
THIS IS REFLECTED.
IN THE JOBS THAT THEY OFFER.
WHEN I MADE IT OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS I WAS FORTUNATE?
THE JOB I FOUND PAID A LIVING
WAGE I WAS OFF SNAP AND OTHER
SOCIAL SERVICE.
I ENVISION A TIME WHEN PROGRAMS
IN JOB TRAINING.
MOVE PEOPLE OFF OF SERVICES AND
AWAY FROM BEING THE WORKING POOR.
THAT'S WHY SUPPORT TEN TWENTY
TWO AND THAT'S MY HOPE FOR THE
CARROT PROGRAM.
THE JOBS ARE.
THAT THE JOBS BE.
SUSTAINABLE JOBS GOOD JOBS.
LIVING WAGE JOBS.
RECENTLY I'VE NEVER BEEN MORE
PROUD OF CALIFORNIA.
THEN WHEN IT STEPS UP TO PROTECT
OUR PEOPLE FROM.
THE MEAN SPIRITED POLICIES
COMING OUT OF WASHINGTON.
I RESPECTFULLY URGENT HI VOTE.
ON AB.
TEN TWENTY TWO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE LEGISLATION FORWARD
AND THANK YOU TO THE SPONSOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
YES MISTER GIBSON.
FIRST OF ALL LET ME SAY -- TO
THIS TO THE AUTHOR OF NUMBER
WICKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL BEFORE US AND
I CAME IN OR TELL AND BY.
RAN DOWN FROM OFFICE FOR A
MEETING WITH THE COUNTY.
OF LOS ANGELES -- CHILD SUPPORT
DEPARTMENT -- AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CAO FRESH SINCE THE TIME
THE CONVERSATION 45% OF THE
PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT ARE
ELIGIBLE BUT YET TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF CAL FOR ASH.
ON THAT'S DISTURBING TO ME --
BUT IS ALSO DISTURBING THAT WE
NEED TO DO MORE AS A LEGISLATOR
LEGISLATIVE BODY AND CERTAINLY I
THINK IT'S A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
I THINK WE HAVE A COMMON THEME
GOING ON AT LEAST THIS YEAR ONE
MAKING SURE HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE
NO LONGER HOMELESS PEOPLE WHO
ARE HUNGRY.
NOT GOING HUNGRY AND I THINK WE
CONTINUE TO WORK IN CONCERT
TOWARDS THAT PARTICULAR GOAL --
WE CAN CERTAINLY SEE SOME OF
THOSE REAL POSITIVE IMPROVEMENTS
IN A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND I'M LOOKING I'M VERY HOPEFUL
THIS GOVERNOR WILL.
EMBRACE -- KNOWING THIS BILL BUT
ALSO OTHERS WILL WE TRYING TO DO.
ART I THINK OUR JOB IS MADAMS
HERE'S TO MAKE PEOPLE'S LIVES
BETTER IN CALIFORNIA IF WE TALK
ABOUT LEADING THE WAY WE HAVE A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY IN THIS TIME.
DURING THIS DISPENSATION TO
REALLY MAKE CALIFORNIA GREAT AND
REALLY LEAD THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AS I WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING THIS -- GOOD
MEASURE BEFORE US -- AND I WOULD
ALSO LOVE TO BE OFFER TO BE
ADDED ON AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I TO WANT TO THANK YOU I WANTED
TO COMMENT.
THAT YOU KNOW.
YOU'RE ONE OF THE GREATEST
ADVOCATES WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
THE QUALITY IN EQUITY AND
INCLUSION AND BRINGING PEOPLE
OUT OF POVERTY.
AND I THINK THAT.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TODAY JUST
REMINDS US THAT WE CAN?
COME UP WE CAN GIVE OUR
TESTIMONY AND IT'S JUST YOU KNOW
SOMETHING WE WE KNOW WE KNOW IT
BY HEART.
BUT THEN THEY'RE SOMETIMES WHAT
IT WOULD JUST IT IT. FOR THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY AND YET WE
HAVE PEOPLE GOING HUNGRY WITH
PEOPLE WHO CANNOT FIND A SHELTER.
AND THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG.
I APPRECIATE ALL THAT YOU DO ALL
THAT YOU DO.
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH.
OF WE HAVE A WE DON'T HAVE A
MOTION.
SO SECOND.
KAY NOW WE DO HAVE A MOTION.
WE DID.
MOVE.
OF THIRTY FOUR FRIEDMAN REAVIS.
WELL YOU KNOW.
MY APOLOGIES TO MISS FRIEDMAN
WAS REVERSED SORRY MR GIPSON
MISTER MATHIS.
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK -- A LOT HAS BEEN SAID --
I THINK FOR MANY OF US THIS IS
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE THIS JOB.
WE'RE DRIVEN TO FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN CREATE THAT SOCIAL SAFETY
NET FOR FOLKS AND I THINK THE
MOMENT THAT WERE AND RIGHT NOW
IN THIS COUNTRY DEMANDS IT --
AND WE CAN LEAD HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND I I BELIEVE IT'S
OUR MORAL OBLIGATION LEADS.
IN THIS COUNTRY AND I JUST THINK
THE ADVOCATES AND REALLY
TRUTHFULLY MOSTLY THE FOLKS HAVE
COMMUTER SHARE THEIR PERSONAL
STORIES.
UNLIKE THOSE STORIES GUIDER
VOTES ON THESE ISSUES SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
PLEASE TAKE THE WRONG.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE RIGHT YES HI RES I
MATHIS.
MATHIS I READ THIS [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE CHOI.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE.
STONE AYE. SIX ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT WE'RE GONNA LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YOU [inaudible]
MR HOLDEN [inaudible]
WHAT
?
MR HOLDEN WELCOME.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU --
MEMBERS OF FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH OUR COMMITTEE
OR WITH OUR STAFF ON THIS BILL
AND DESPITE.
OF THE LENGTH AND COMPLEXITY OF
THIS BILL WE APPRECIATE THE
GREAT WORK -- THAT WAS PROVIDED
TO US TO HELP GUIDE US.
SECONDLY I WANT LIKE TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEES THE MINUTES.
OF THE AMENDMENTS PROVIDE A
FOUNDATION UPON WHICH FUTURE
LEGISLATION COULD STAND.
AB SIXTY NO WAY PERHAPS
PROHIBITS THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES FROM REQUIRING A
PERSON OF SELF TO SELF DISCLOSE
THEIR OWN CONVICTIONS AND
THEREFORE CREATING.
A CANDOR TROUT.
IT ALSO CODIFIES LANGUAGE THAT
REINFORCE THE USE OF SIMPLIFIED
EXEMPTIONS.
AND ENSURES MORE PEOPLE RECEIVE
CLEARANCE TO WORK AS EFFICIENTLY
AS POSSIBLE.
THE BILL ALSO CALLS ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
BEGIN COLLECTING DATA FROM
CLARENCE AN EXEMPTION
APPLICATION SPECIFICALLY.
DEMOGRAPHICS ON AGE ETHNICITY
GENDER AND CONVICTED CRIMES FOR
APPLICATIONS THAT ARE DENIED
CLEARANCE AND EXEMPTIONS.
CURRENTLY THIS INFORMATION IS
NOT COLLECTED FROM APPLICATIONS
THAT ARE DENIED OR GRANTED
CLEARANCE OR EXEMPTIONS WHICH IS
A GREAT DISSERVICE TO THE
FACILITIES AND LEGAL CENTERS
THAT FIGHT EVERYDAY. FOR THESE
APPLICANTS RIGHTS TO WORK.
THIS DATA WILL SHOW THE
CONSISTENT OP OPPRESSION OF
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES WHICH
WILL HIGHLIGHT IN DEMAND FOR
GREATER CHANGE IN OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM.
WE GET EVERYONE ON EVERYONE TO
THE TABLE AND WITH THIS LANGUAGE
WE WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE REAL
CHANGE TOGETHER.
I THEREFORE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON A. B..
SIXTEEN OH EIGHT AND TESTIFYING
TODAY IS SABINA COR SAID HE FROM
PRISONERS WITH CHILDREN AND A J.
JILL OIL.
MERRICK WHO ALSO REPRESENTS THE
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH THIS PLEASE
THANK YOU HONORABLE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS SABINA CROSS CITY.
I AM AN ATTORNEY AND THE POLICY
MANAGER WITH LEGAL SERVICES FOR
PERSONS WITH CHILDREN AND ONE OF
THE ORGANIZATIONAL CO SPONSORS
ON THIS BILL WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN.
ELLIS P. C. WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT AND WORKS
TO RESTORE THE CIVIL AND HUMAN
RIGHTS OF FORMALLY AND CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE.
WE ARE HERE TODAY TO ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR A BI.
SIXTEEN OH EIGHT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES A LONG STANDING
PROBLEM WITH GETTING LICENSING
PERMITS AND CERTIFICATIONS TO
WORK IN THE AREA OF CHILD CARE.
RESIDENTIAL NURSING AND
GENERALLY THE CARE OF CARE OF
INDIVIDUALS -- CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES ANY PERSON WHO HAS A
CONVICTION HISTORY FOR ANYTHING
OTHER THAN A TRAFFIC TICKET TO
APPLY FOR AN EXEMPTION TO BE
ELIGIBLE TO WORK.
EVEN IF THE CONDUCT CONVICTION
IS UNRELATED TO THE WORK AND IS
DECADES OLD.
THIS EXEMPTION PROCESS IS
ONEROUS AND OFTEN CAN TAKE
UPWARDS OF SIX MONTHS TO
COMPLETE.
AS A RESULT MANY OTHERWISE
QUALIFIED APPLICANTS MISSED JOB
OPPORTUNITIES SINCE JOBS COULD
NOT BE HELD OPEN UNTIL THE
PROCESS IS FINISHED.
OUR COALITION PARTNERS AT THE
EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW CENTER
HAVE CONDUCTED -- OR LOOKED
RESEARCH INTO HOW THE PROCESS
AFFECTS APPLICANTS FOR THESE
JOBS AND FOUND THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THOSE IMPACTED BY
THIS PROCESS ARE WOMEN OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND LOOKED LATINO WOMEN.
WHO COMPRISE THE BULK OF
INDIVIDUALS DOING THIS WORK?
AB SIXTEEN OH EIGHT AS AMENDED --
HAS THREE COMPONENTS IT REQUIRES
THE D. S. S. S. TO KEEP BETTER
DATA REGARDING THE EXEMPTION
PROCESS.
IT ELIMINATES THE CANDOR TRAP
WHICH REQUIRES INDIVIDUALS TO
SELF DISCLOSE INFORMATION THEY
MAY NOT KNOW REGARDING THEIR OWN
CRIMINAL RECORD.
AND FINALLY IT BRINGS A
SIMPLIFIED EXEMPTION PROCESS
INTO STATUTE.
THIS THIRD PART IS MOST
IMPORTANT BECAUSE IT WILL ALLOW
US TO HAVE FURTHER DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE CHILD CARE ADVOCATES
ABOUT THE APPROPRIATE PEOPLE TO
QUALIFY FOR THIS SIMPLIFIED
PROCESS -- WE'VE CONFIRMED WITH
THE S. S. THAT THE SIMPLIFY
PROCESS WILL TAKE ONLY TWO WEEKS
AS OPPOSED TO THE NORMAL
EXEMPTION PROCESS WHICH CAN TAKE
UP TO SIX MONTHS.
DATA WE RECEIVE FROM THE DSS
SHOWS THAT DURING A SIX MINUTE
PERIOD LESS THAN 10% OF THE
PEOPLE WHO APPLIED FOR AN
EXEMPTION WERE ACTUALLY DENIED
BECAUSE OF THEIR CRIMINAL RECORD.
BUT A MAJORITY OF OVER SIX
THOUSAND DROPPED OUT OF THE
PROCESSORS PROCESS OR HAD THEIR
APPLICATIONS WITHDRAW -- DUE
SOLELY TO THE LAND AND
COMPLEXITY OF THE PROCESS.
THIS BILL SUPPORT ALSO SUPPORTS
PUBLIC SAFETY SINCE MANY OF
THOSE WHO LOSE JOB OPPORTUNITIES
DUE TO THE ONEROUS EXEMPTION
PROCESS WILL OFTEN FIND JOBS
DOING THE SAME WORK THAT ARE NOT
LICENSED POSITIONS.
THEY DO NOT BENEFIT FROM
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT IN
THOSE POSITIONS HAVE ACCESS TO
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND ARE NOT
LICENSE SO WE DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY THEM SHOULD
ISSUES ARISE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP TO CORRECT
THIS AND MAKE LICENSING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OTHERWISE
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS WITH
CONVICTION HISTORIES MORE
READILY AVAILABLE.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TO PASS A
BE SIXTEEN AWAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT
WE THOUGHT YES OF THANK YOU OF
MY NAME IS JAIL MYRICK AND I'M
WITH THE EAST BAY COMMITTEE LAW
CENTER AND I'LL JUST BRIEFLY SAY
YOU KNOW WE WORK WITH CLIENTS ON
A REGULAR BASIS.
AND ON A WEEKLY BASIS WITH THE
CLIENTS WHO HAVE.
WHO HAVE A PAST RECORD WERE
TRYING TO MAKE THEIR LIVES
BETTER AND ARMED WE STILL
COULDN'T WHEN TERMS A DSS IN
PARTICULAR WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF
IT AND ANECDOTALLY WE STARTED
NOTICING A PATTERN WHERE WAS A
LOT OF TIMES IT WAS?
OLDER WOMEN A LOT OF TIMES IT
WAS WOMEN OF COLOR ESPECIALLY
AFRICAN AMERICAN WOMEN AND WE
LOOKED AT OUR OWN DATA AND WE
FOUND THAT 55% OF THE WOMEN WE
HELP GOING TO THIS PROCESS.
THAT WE HOPE WONDERS PROCESS
WERE SPECIFICALLY AFRICAN
AMERICAN WOMEN SO THAT SHOWS
THAT THERE'S CLEARLY ARM OF A
ISSUE THAT -- FURTHERING ARM IN
A SEXUALITY -- AND OPPRESSION OF
FOLKS WHO ARE.
ALREADY STRUGGLING -- BUT THEN
WE'RE ALSO SEEING HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE GOING THROUGH THIS
ARE PEOPLE ARE DROPPING OUT JUST
BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW HOW IT
WORKS AND WITH THE HELP OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN WERE ABLE
TO GET SOME NUMBERS.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR A SIX MONTH PERIOD
AND WE FOUND THAT.
OF THE PEOPLE THAT WOULD TO THIS
PROCESS IN THE SIX MONTH PERIOD
OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND PEOPLE DID
IT BUT LESS THAN EIGHT HUNDRED
ACTUALLY WERE DENIED BECAUSE OF
THEIR CRIMINAL RECORD.
THE BIGGEST GROUP WERE NOT
PEOPLE DENIED OR APPROVED BUT AS
SABINA MENTION WERE FOLKS WHO
DROPPED OUT DURING THE PROCESS.
SIX THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE PEOPLE DROPPED OUT
BECAUSE OF THE LENGTH AND THE
COMPLEXITY OF THE PROCESS SO.
THERE'S CLEARLY A PROBLEM HERE
THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED ARM WE
HAVE BEEN.
SO HONORED TO WORK WITH SOME OF
THE FOLKS IN THE CHILDCARE.
INDUSTRY WHO.
ADDITIONALLY HAVE SOME DOUBTS
ABOUT THIS BILL BUT I THINK
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT WAYS
THAT WE CAN GET. TO THE SAME
PLACE AND WE'RE I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THEM TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
SOLVE THIS ISSUE -- AND SOLVE
THIS PROCESS ISSUE IN A WAY THAT
ALLOWS FOLKS TO GET TO WORK.
ARMED WITH OUT.
WITHOUT CREATING ANY ISSUE ON
PUBLIC SAFETY SO WITH THIS
AMENDMENT ALLOWS THAT TO GO
FORWARD AND WE HOPE THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT THAT.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER ONE I THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR OFFERING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BELL MANY TIMES
OUR SOCIAL WORKERS WANT TO GET
THEY NEED TO GET AN INTERNSHIP
WHILE THEY'RE GETTING THERE --
UNDERGRADUATE AND GRADUATE
DEGREE IN SOCIAL WORK AND MANY
COME FROM COMMUNITIES OF POVERTY
SOME COME FROM THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM SOME DO HAVE PASSED
INTERACTION WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND WHEN THEY TRY TO GET THEIR
INTERNSHIP IT TAKES SIX MONTHS
SO THEY LOSE THEIR INTERNSHIPS
AND THEY CAN'T GET THE
INTERNSHIP THEY NEED -- OR
THEY'D LOSE OUT ON JOB
OPPORTUNITIES WHEN THEY GRADUATE
SO WE STRONGLY SUPPORT WHAT THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS DEALING AND
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KAELIN DEAN WITH THE ALLIANCE
FOR BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AT
POLICY LINK WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND AUTHOR AS
WELL AS MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY
I MEAN TO ME COMMITTEE.
AND WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
I SPAWNING AS WITH ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION OR PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THE OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE FEEL IT'S IMPORTANT
TO PROVIDE A REAL AVENUE TOWARDS
A CAREER PATH FOR PEOPLE THAT A
FORM INCARCERATED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- I'M SORT OF IN
THE MIDDLE SO IS THAT OKAY.
OKAY MY NAME IS MY SHOULD CALL
THEM FROM THE CHILD CARE
LAWCENTER AND WE INITIALLY DID
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THIS BILL.
WHICH IS WHY WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER OF OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED -- WE HAVE REVIEWED THE
AMENDMENTS AND WE FOUGHT THE
BILL IS GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
SO WE WOULD LOVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE FOR US IT'S CHILDREN.
ARE BEING PROTECTED AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU ARE TRYING
TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS WE WANT
PEOPLE TO BE COME CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
PROTECT OUR CHILDREN AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE REALLY WANT TO
WORK WITH YOU ON TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE WE'RE DOING THE BEST.
WE CAN DO FOR BOTH POPULATIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING YOU BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THANK YOU MISTER
HOLDEN FOR BRINGING THIS FOR WE
ARE FORCED TO DO OF THE SYSTEM.
THAT TENDS TO PUNISH AND THEN RE
PUNISHING REPLENISH AND WE NEED
TO PUT A LOT OF PEOPLE TO WORK
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT YOU'RE
FACILITATING SO I APPRECIATE
THIS.
AND YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER I AND AND
YOU'VE YOU'VE SAID IT VERY --
APROPOS.
IT'S ABOUT ALSO GIVEN A SECOND
CHANCE AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
SOMETIMES THE SYSTEM DOESN'T
ALWAYS ALLOW FOR THAT.
AND SYSTEMATICALLY WHAT'S BUILT
INTO THE SYSTEM IS.
BUREAUCRACY AND WE'RE TRYING TO
GET AROUND THAT BUT WE ALSO ARE
AS THE OF THE LAST -- PRISONER --
DOES STATED WE ARE WE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION BECAUSEWE DO
RECOGNIZE THAT IS A A COMMUNITY --
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT --
WE'RE WE'RE TAKING ALL THE
PROPER PRECAUTIONS AS WELL TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE.
ULTIMATELY GOING TO BE PROVIDING
SERVICES.
TO CHILDREN AND YOUTH AND ALSO
SENIORS THAT -- THAT THAT
THERE'S PROPER SAFEGUARDS IN
PLACE AND SO WE'RE WE'RE NOT
GOING TO IGNORE THAT PART WE
HAVEN'T -- AND LOOKING AT THE SO
WONDERFUL WITNESSES OF THIS IS
THE SECOND TIME AROUND THE THE
BLOCK FORCE WE HAD THIS BILL OUT
LAST YEAR AND AND IT'S SOMEWHAT.
SIMILAR FORM AND AND SO I'M
REALLY.
PROUD OF THEIR COMMITMENT AND
STICKING WITH US AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
WORKING WITH US AND ALL OF YOU
AND YOUR YOUR SUPPORT GOING
FORWARD SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND IN THE MOTION IS.
THE PASS IS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE [inaudible]
RAMOS.
MATHIS NO MATHIS KNOWN REAVIS
[inaudible]
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE BY STONE AYE.
BUT IT'S THREE TO ONE WILL PUT
THE MEASURE ON CALL.
THANK YOU.
I THINK MRS THEIR INVESTORS AREA.
SO THIS TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE A. B..
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
[inaudible]
AND STAFF.
AS A COMPONENT OF THE MASTER
PLAN FOR AGING AB ELEVEN THIRTY
SIX REPLACES THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING WITH THE NEW DEPARTMENT.
OF COMMUNITY LIVING.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE.
COORDINATED LEADERSHIP AND
ADDRESSES THE NEEDS OF OLDER
ADULTS PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
AND CARE GIVERS.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGING WAS ESTABLISHED AS THE
STATE ENTITY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAMS
PROVIDED BY THE OLDER
CALIFORNIANS ACT THE CA.
AUTHORIZED CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
PROGRAM SERVING OLDER ADULTS AND
THEIR HOMES AND COMMUNITIES IN
ADDITION CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF AGING THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES OUR WRISTS BUT
SOCIAL SERVICES ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR DELIVERING.
A RANGE OF SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIA'S OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES OFTEN
WITH DUPLICATION AND WITHOUT
ADMINISTRATIVE EFFICIENCY.
THESE DEPARTMENTS OPERATE IN A
FRAGMENTED FASHION OFTEN WITH
LITTLE DATA SHARING AND POLICY
DEVELOPMENT ACROSS PROGRAMS THIS
FRAGMENTATION IMPACTS THE
ABILITY TO DELIVER SERVICES TO
OLDER ADULTS.
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
CARE GIVERS IN A COORDINATED
STREAMLINED FASHION THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO BE BETTER SERVED.
FOR YEARS STATE POLICYMAKERS
HAVE CALLED FOR STRUCTURAL
REORGANIZATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING YET THE
VARIOUS RESTRUCTURING PROPOSALS
HAVE NOT BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
GIVEN THE GROWTH AND THE AGING
POPULATION THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMUNITY LIVING WILL ENSURE
THAT OUR SENIORS PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WILL RECEIVE THE SERVICES THAT
THEY HAVE SO DESPERATELY SOUGHT.
A WITH ME ARE A TERREL KELCH
WITH C. FOR A AND CHRISTINE
MILLS.
UP IN ON AND ON ACT AND THINK
YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND FIRST WITNESS
PLEASE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
KRISTINA MALES AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
FOUNDATION FOR INDEPENDENT
LIVING CENTERS WE ARE A
MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION SERVING
TWENTY TWO OF CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY EIGHT INDEPENDENT LIVING
CENTERS.
CENTERS HAVE BEEN.
IN OPERATION FOR OVER FORTY
YEARS THEY ARE DISABILITY
SERVICES AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS LED BY AND FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
THROUGHOUT THESE YEARS WE HAVE
SEEN THE FRAGMENTED.
SERVICES OFFERED BETWEEN PEOPLE
WHO ARE AGING AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND AS A RESULT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD TO
CREATE.
A SYSTEMS AND SUPPORT AREAS OF
IMPROVEMENT THROUGH A SUCH
PROGRAMS AS AGING AND DISABILITY
RESOURCE CONNECTIONS AND THE
STATEWIDE EIGHTY R. C. ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
MY PASS CHAIR ON ACTON.
WHO IS ALSO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE FREED CENTER FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING I SHE WILL
TALK ABOUT THE REASONS WHY WE%
SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT THIS IS
ONE OF OUR PRIORITY BILLS FOR
THE YEAR AND WE ARE EXCITED TO
BE WORKING WITH ASSEMBLY NIZARI
IN?
OFFICE ON IT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ON A ACT
THEN -- SO WE'RE REALLY EXCITED
TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION WITH
YOU -- A FREED AS PART OF IN THE
AGING AND DISABILITY RESOURCE
CONNECTION OF NEVADA COUNTY WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH OUR AREA
AGENCY ON AGING AND ELEVEN
EXTENDED PARTNERS FROM HOSPICE.
TO MEDICAL CLINICS TO THE
REGIONAL CENTER TO WORK TO
STREAMLINE ACCESS TO SERVICES
FOR INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS OF
WHAT AGE THEY ARE WHAT TYPE
DISABILITY THEY HAVE AND WHAT
INCOME THAT THEY HAVE.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL TO COORDINATE
THOSE SERVICES THROUGH CROSS
TRAINING ACROSS ORGANIZATIONS
WARM HAND OPS -- AND
COLLABORATIVE MEETINGS TO
DISCUSS THE COMMUNITY NEEDS AND
GAPS IN SERVICES.
WHAT I THINK IS INTERESTING TO
NOTE IS THAT ON THE LOCAL LEVEL
THERE THERE ARE SOME KEY
ELEMENTS OF DEVELOPING
STREAMLINED ACCESS TO SERVICES
AND NO WRONG DOOR SYSTEMS?
ANDON THE LOCAL LEVEL WE'VE
DEVELOPED THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
FOR REFERRAL TRUSTED REFERRALS
AND ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
ORGANIZATIONS TO MAKE REFERRALS
AS WELL AS PROVIDING PERSON
CENTERED INDIVIDUAL IS
INDIVIDUALIZED TYPE SERVICES.
WHAT WE REALLY STRUGGLED WITH ON
A LOCAL LEVEL IS ONE STATE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS TOPIC AS WELL
AS UNIVERSAL ASSESSMENTS AND
WAYS?
TO COLLECT DATA TO DEMONSTRATE
OUTCOMES AND TO BE ABLE TO
BETTER COORDINATE SERVICES
ACROSS THE ORGANIZATION SAID
THIS BILL ATTEMPTS TO DO THAT --
WE REALLY NEED CONSISTENCY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL THERE ARE QUITE A FEW
LOCAL ORGANIZATIONS WORKING
TOGETHER THROUGH THE EIGHTY OUR
SEASON OTHER INITIATIVES FOR NO
WRONG DOOR.
BUT WE NEED THAT KIND OF
CONSISTENCY ACROSS ORGAN AND
COUNTIES AND JURISDICTIONS.
WE REALLY NEED TO LOOK AT
SYSTEMS ALIGNMENT WE HAVE ALL
THESE SILOS PROGRAMS YOU KNOW --
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE WE WORK
WITH THAT MAY NOT BE -- AN OLDER
ADULT THAT NEED ACCESS FOR
EXAMPLE TO A HOME DELIVERED MEAL
BUT THEY'RE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT.
SO WE'RE CONSTANTLY WORKING ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL TO NAVIGATE
PEOPLE TO HOME MODIFICATIONS TO
OTHER EL TSS SYSTEMS.
THAT WOULD BENEFIT THEM TO BE
ABLE TO LIVE SAFELY -- AND
INDEPENDENTLY IN THEIR HOME AS
LONG AS THEY WOULD LIKE TO LIVE
THERE.
SO WE'RE REALLY LOOKING FOR
SYSTEMS ALIGNMENT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR WAYS TO BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE
INDIVIDUALS.
THROUGH THE VERY SILENCE SYSTEMS
AND WE REALLY ARE LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO BE ABLE TO INCENTIVIZE
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT SYSTEMS
ALIGNMENT AND SO THIS PROPOSAL
IS ONE WAY WE SEE THIS ON THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON COMMUNITY
LIVING.
WE'VE BROUGHT TOGETHER AGING WE
BROUGHT TOGETHER DISABILITY --
AND WORK TOGETHER TO HELP
INCREASE ACCESS AND LEOPARD I
LIMITED RESOURCES SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITNESSES WITH.
IT MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TERRA CELTS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF AREA
AGENCIES ON AGING.
CALIFORNIA'S SYSTEM OF HOME
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES.
HIS AT BEST A PIECEMEAL APPROACH
THEIR OVER THIRTY FIVE PROGRAMS
IN SOMETHING LIKE FIVE
DEPARTMENTS.
THAT ARE TRYING TO SERVE THIS
POPULATION.
IS JUST A VERY COMPLEX AND
CONFUSING SYSTEM.
FINDING SERVICES TO MEET
INDIVIDUAL'S NEEDS CAN BE
DIFFICULT FOR OLDER PEOPLE IN
THEIR CARE TAKERS.
AB ONE ELEVEN THIRTY SIX WILL
INCORPORATE.
THE HOME COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE DISABILITIES UNDER
ONE DEPARTMENT.
A WE BELIEVE THAT A SINGLE
DEPARTMENT WILLING.
COORDINATED POLICY DEVELOPMENT
FOR LONG TERM CARE SERVICES.
LET ME INDICATE.
I'M NOT TOO SURE.
THAT IS IT'S THAT YOU'RE AWARE
OF THIS BUT THIS IS A HISTORIC
MOMENT. FOR THE DISABILITY AND
THE INDEPENDENT LIVING CENTERS
TO BE AT THE SAME TABLE IN
SUPPORT OF A THE SAME BILL. FOR
YEARS THE TWO COMMUNITIES REALLY
HAD DIFFICULTY UNDERSTANDING ONE
ANOTHER.
HAND ALWAYS FELT THAT WE
COMPETED. FOR FOR A THE SAME
RESOURCES.
WE'VE COME TOGETHER ON THIS BILL.
AND IT'S A IT'S A MAJOR BILL FOR
BOTH OF THIS IS HAS CRISTINA
SAID.
HANNAH I JUST WANT. TO TO MAKE
YOU AWARE.
OF THAT TO HAVING NEEDS TO
COMMUNITY SAID HERE -- IT SPEAKS
VOLUMES IN TERMS OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL AND THE
WELL WE HOPE TO SEE.
HER WILL RESULT FROM THIS BILL
SO THANK YOU.
YOUR SUPPORT OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
YOU MY NAME IS LISA COLEMAN I'M
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION AND I
VERY MUCH WANT TO ECHO.
THE HISTORIC.
THE DARKNESS OF THIS BILL AS
DARYL CAL SAID UP. 40% OF
RESIDENTS IN SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY ARE ARE UNDER THE AGE
OF SIXTY FIVE LONG TERM SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS IS NOT SO MUCH A
FUNCTION OF AGE AS IT IS THE
FUNCTION OF HEALTH.
AND WE CREATE.
DUPLICITOUS SYSTEMS THAT ARE
COSTLY TO THE STATE WHEN WE
DON'T RECOGNIZE THAT IT IS ABOUT
HEALTH AND NOT ABOUT AGE SO
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL AND WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MIKE BYNUM EW ASKED ME -- THIRTY
NINE THIRTY ON BEHALF OF OUR ONE
HUNDRED TEN I JUST AS WORKERS
AND THE CLIENTS WERE IN FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MOTION.
HE DID OKAY.
GOOD OF THIS IS THERE THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FOR THINK.
WITH WHAT THE GOVERNOR HAS.
INDICATED BOTH WITH EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND MAYBE A
NEW LOOK AT AGING PEOPLE
DISABILITIES A STRONGER SET OF
SUPPORT SERVICES.
HOPEFULLY THE ADMINISTRATION
WILL BE AMENABLE ARE MUCH MORE
AMENABLE THAN THEY HAD BEEN IN
THE PAST TO A PROPOSAL LIKE THIS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING.
FOR THANK YOU THE FOR THE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISSIVES
THERE YOU MAY CLOSE OUT OF TAKE
THAT AS A CLOSE AS WELL AS A
WITH.
THE COLLAPSE LED COLLABORATIVE
VOICES HAVE SAID AMONGST THE THE
THREE WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CULTURAL PLEASE
RAMOS.
MATHIS REVA [inaudible]
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON I MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE BY STONE AYE.
THAT IS THREE ZERO WHO PUT ALL
CALL WOULD WANT TO GET OTHER
MEMBERS WILL I'M SURE COMPLETE
THE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
RIGHT MISTER LEVINE [inaudible]
TEXAS.
TO ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
[inaudible]
SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX YEAH
.
WE ARE AT THE THE END OR NEAR
THE END. FOR FOR YOU I THINK
[inaudible]
HI.
SO WHAT MR MEMBERS I PRESENTE BE
SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX RELATING TO
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES THIS
BILL WILL PROHIBIT THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
FROM GRANTING A CRIMINAL RECORD
CLEARANCE.
OR EXEMPTION UNTIL IT RECEIVED
AN INDIVIDUAL STATE AND FEDERAL
RECORD.
CRIMINAL RECORD DSS IS TASKED
WITH PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
PRESENT IN THE CARE FACILITIES
IT LICENSES WHICH INCLUDES.
THE PROPER VETTING OF STAFF THAT
PROVIDE SERVICES TO THESE
CLIENTS IN TWENTY SIXTEEN A
STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT FOUND
THAT IN SOME CASES DSS FAILED.
TO OBTAIN SELF DISCLOSURE FORMS
DETAILING IN INDIVIDUALS OUT OF
STATE CRIMINAL HISTORY AND
GRANTED OCCURRENCE IN ADVANCE
RECEIVING THE FEDERAL CRIMINAL
HISTORY.
THIS FAILURE TO REVIEW AN
INDIVIDUAL'S COMPLETE CRIMINAL
HISTORY CREATES A SITUATION
WHEREBY DANGEROUS OR ON
AUTHORIZED INDIVIDUALS CAN BE
GRANTED ACCESS TO FACILITIES
THAT HOUSE OR PROVIDE SERVICES
TO VULNERABLE POPULATIONS HERE
WITH ME TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS REGARDING THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT.
IS MISTER BOB HARRIS FROM THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU DID YOU ARE
PERCENTAGES AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS I CAN DO WHATEVER THE
COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE I HAVE A
SHORT LITTLE A BRIEF AMOUNT OF
DETAIL I CAN PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE IF THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S GOING OF INTEREST.
SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME'S BOB HARRIS I'M AN AUDIT
PRINCIPLE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICEI WAS
ALSO THE PROJECT MANAGER ON OUR
MOST RECENT AUDIT OF THE CARE
GIVER BACKGROUND CHECK BUREAU.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT SOCIAL
SERVICES -- I WON'T REPEAT WHAT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALREADY
COVERED I WILL JUST -- REITERATE
THAT -- OUR OFFICE DOESN'T TAKE
A FORMAL POSITION ON BILLS BUT
THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS A
RECOMMENDATION WE MADE AS PART
OF OUR AUDIT SPECIFICALLY BUT
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES BE REQUIRED TO WAIT FOR
BOTH THE STATE BACKGROUND CHECK
INFORMATION THE STATE CRIMINAL
HISTORY INFORMATION.
AND TO THE FEDERAL CRIMINAL
HISTORY INFORMATION BEFORE
GRANTING ACCESS TO A LICENSED
CARE FACILITY -- CURRENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT DOESN'T WAIT FOR EVEN
THE SELF DISCLOSURE FORM WHERE
INDIVIDUALS WOULD REPORT WHETHER
THEY HAD OTHER OUT OF STATE
CONVICTIONS BEFORE GRANTING
ACCESS.
I WILL NOT THOUGH WE ALSO LOOKED
AT WHETHER THIS WOULD THIS
CHANGE TO THE LAW WOULD
UNREASONABLY DELAY THE
BACKGROUND CHECK PROCESS AND
FOUND -- BASED ON THE DATA THAT
WE REVIEWED THAT IT WOULD NOT TO
DELAY THAT BACKGROUND CHECK
PROCESS AN UNREASONABLE FASHION
ESSENTIALLY THE STATE CRIMINAL
HISTORY INFORMATION IS DELIVERED
TO SOCIAL SERVICES AROUND THE
SAME TIME OR EVEN AFTER THE
FEDERAL CRIMINAL HISTORY
INFORMATION SO WE DIDN'T SEE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THERE.
WOULD BE UNREASONABLE DELAYS TO
THE BACKGROUND CHECK PROCESS
THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS OUR
RECOMMENDATION AND IF THE
COMMITTEE HAS ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
THEM.
THANK YOU.
WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADELINE COOPER
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M BOB NAYLOR
I REPRESENT SIX BEDS INK WHICH
IS AN ASSOCIATION OF SMALL
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITIES ABOUT
TWO THOUSAND OR MORE IN.
ALL OVER THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WE DO NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE ARE
SEEKING.
THE DATA.
THAT WAS THE THAT WAS TALKED
ABOUT BY THE AUDITOR AND THE
DATA ABOUT THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THE FEDERAL BACKGROUND CHECK.
PROVIDES NEW INFORMATION
COMPARED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE OUR CONCERN IS AN
INADVERTENT DELAY IN THE ABILITY
TO FILL VACANCIES IN OUR STAFF
AND I WOULD.
I WOULD HARKEN BACK TO MR
HOLDEN'S VILLE -- WHICH WAS
TRYING TO ADDRESS UNREASONABLE
DELAYS IN GETTING -- EXEMPTIONS
FROM THE FROM.
A ISSUES RAISED BY THE
BACKGROUND CHECKS SO.
WE'RE WORKING WE WANT TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR ON THOSE WERE
NOT OPPOSED TO THE BILL BUT
WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE IS THERE IN
TERMS OF AVOIDING UNNECESSARY
DELAYS IN HIRING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE OPPOSE ARE
CONCERNED.
ALL RIGHT SEEN ENTERING A BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
THAT'S FRIEDMAN ACTUALLY MISTER
NAYLOR -- BROUGHT UP -- THE
QUESTION I HAD WHICH WAS AND HOW
DOES THIS RELATE AND MAYBE IT'S
NOT A FAIR QUESTION BECAUSE IT'S
SOMEBODY ELSE'S BILL BUT I'M
WONDERING HOW THIS RELATES TO
DOESN'T RELATE TO THEM.
MR HOLDEN SPELL THAT WE JUST
HEARD UNABLE TO COMMENT ON THAT
[inaudible]
MOVE THERE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION AS
THEIR SECOND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD -- DIVORCES I GET OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE NO
THE STERLING YOU MAY CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU AND THAT MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE RAMOS [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
REVERSE [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE BY STONE I THREE ZERO BUT
THE BILL A CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I GET UP WHEN WE GET MORE
MEMBERS BACK.
IF WE COULD GET MEMBERS FACTS WE
COULD COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS IN
THE MEANTIME I'LL TAKE A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA.
SO.
THIS FRIEDMAN AND THEN MISTER
GIBSON AS A SECONDS.
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR RADIUS.
MATHIS REVAMPS CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I A GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN STONE BY
STONE AYE.
THANK YOU.
THAT IS THREE ZERO THEY CONSENT
AGENDA IS ALSO.
A CALL TO LET CAN WE ROLL
THROUGH THE THE BILLS AS THEY
ARE I'M NOT SURE WHICH ONES ARE
ON CALL OR NOT BUT LEAST GET THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE HERE TO BE ABLE
TO VOTE.
AND CATCH UP [inaudible]
WILLOWS HERE'S SO STARTING WITH
WITH.
BUT I WANT THEM.
TO FILE ITEM TO AB ONE SIXTY
THREE CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TO
ZERO CHOI [inaudible]
GIPSON.
HI GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
KERN VOTE.
FIVE ZERO THANK YOU ITEM THREE
WAS PULLED ITEM.
FOR ITEM FOR AB FIVE THIRTY SIX
CURRENT VOTED SIX TO ZERO CHOI.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE CURRENT VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO NUMBER SEVEN AB.
SEVEN TWENTY ONE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TWO ZERO CHOI.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB EIGHT
TWELVE CURRENT AT SIX TO ZERO
OKAY.
TEN TWENTY TWO WAIT THEIR NUMBER --
DOING START FROM THE TOP YEAH.
NO NO LET'S JUST KEEP GOING
THROUGH SO WHERE SO YEAH I LET
HIM EIGHT AB.
EIGHT AB WELL CURRENT VOTER SIX
TO THE ZERO CHOI.
WHICH ONE FILE ITEM EIGHT AB.
EIGHT ONE TWO YES CHOI I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT ZERO FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
TEN TWENTY TWO CURRENT VOTED SIX
TO ZERO CHOI.
CHU I KNOW MAIENSCHEIN.
CURRENT VOTE.
SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM TWELVE AB
ELEVEN THIRTY SIX CURRENCY VOTE
IS THREE TO ZERO RADIUS.
REYES HI MATHIS [inaudible]
REMUS.
CHOI.
CHOI NO.
MAIENSCHEIN.
CURRENT VOTE.
FOR ONE FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB
TWELVE TWENTY ONE CURRENT VOTERS
FOUR TO ZERO CHOI.
YES CHOI I GIPSON GIPSON AYE
MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE BY STONE AYE AYE CURRENT
VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
AB TWELVE NINETY FIVE KERN
VOTERS THREE TO ONE CHOI.
CHU I KNOW GIPSON.
GIPSON I'D MAIENSCHEIN.
STONE.
JOHN I CURRENT VOTE.
FIVE TO TWO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A.
B..
THIRTEEN ZERO ONE CURRENT VOTE
IS FOUR TO ZERO CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING GIPSON.
GIPSON I MAIENSCHEIN.
CURRENT VOTE FIVE DESERVE.
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN A. B. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY NINE CURRENT VOTE OF SIX
TO ZERO CHOI.
CHOI I AM MAIENSCHEIN -- VOTE.
SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIXTEEN ZERO
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE IS.
THREE TWO ZERO RIGHT YES.
REYES I REQUEST [inaudible]
YES.
I THREE ONE SORRY.
THREE TO ONE KERN BUT THREE TO
ONE REYES I READ US.
CHOI.
CHU I KNOW MAIENSCHEIN.
CURRENT VOTE.
FORTY TWO FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX CURRENT
VOTE.
THREE TO ZERO RAMOS.
REYES AYE MATHIS.
LEAVE US.
CHOI.
CHOI I MAIENSCHEIN.
CURRENT VOTE [inaudible] FIVE
ZERO ONE WE CAN STOP IT FROM THE
TOP YEAH ARE YOUR ATTENTION
WHEREVER. FOR POLITICAL REASONS
[inaudible]
THAT'S COMING.
CONTROL OVER HER RECORDS WITH
[inaudible]
THIS ORDER -- ARE ORGANIZED
STOCK MARKET. FIVE OF THE SEVEN
WHAT YOU NEED.
WHATEVER I'M MISSING -- CONSENT.
OR THE STOCK [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
TALKING CLOCK.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
VOTERS THREE TO ZERO FRANCE ON
RACE I'D MATHIS.
REMUS CHORE.
CONSENT.
CHOI I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
CURRENT VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM ONE AB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN CURRENT
VOTER SEVEN TO ZERO CHOI.
CHOI I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM TO AB
ONE SIXTY THREE CURRENT VOTE IS
FIVE TWO ZERO CHOI.
CHOI NOT VOTING MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I FINAL VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM FOR AB
FIVE THIRTY SIX CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN TWO ZERO CHOI.
CHOI I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM SEVEN A.
B. SEVEN TWENTY ONE CURRENT
VOTED SIX TO ZERO CHOI.
CHOI ARE AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
EIGHT TWELVE CURRENT VOTE FINAL
VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM ELEVEN
AB TEN TWENTY TWO CURRENT VOTE
IS SEVEN TO ZERO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I AM FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM TWELVE
AB ELEVEN THIRTY SIX CURRENT
VOTE FOUR TO ONE MATHIS
[inaudible]
RETURNS [inaudible]
REVERSE I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I CURRENT WROTE
[inaudible]
SIX TO ONE I'M FROM.
I'M SORRY FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB
TEN TWENTY TWO FINAL VOTE.
SEVEN TO ONE FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
A. B. TWELVE TWENTY ONE CURRENT
VOTER SEVEN TO ZERO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I'VE FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
AB TWELVE NINETY FIVE CURRENT
VOTE FIVE TWO TWO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I A FINAL VOTE.
SIX TO TWO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A.
B. THIRTEEN A ONE CURRENT VOTE
FIVE TWO ZERO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I FINAL VOTE.
SIX TO ZERO FILE ITEM SIXTEEN A.
B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY NINE CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN I FINAL VOTE.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM NINETEEN
AB SIXTEEN ZERO EIGHT CURRENT
VOTE FOR TWO TO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN NOT FIGHTING FINAL
VOTE.
FOR TO TO FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
AB SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX CURRENT
VOTE FIVE TWO ZERO MATHIS.
REVERSE REVERSE I MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I KERN VOTE SEVEN
DESERVE [inaudible]
LARA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REVERSE ON FILE
ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY SIXTEEN
ZERO EIGHT THE CURRENT VOTERS.
FOR TO TO REVERSE REVERSE I KERN
VOTE.
FIVE TO ZERO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR KERN VOTED SIX TO ZERO
MATHIS.
READ US RIVERSIDE CURRENT VOTE.
SEVEN TO ZERO THE CHIEF OF AND I
WOULD.
HOPE THAT -- YEAH
[inaudible]
ON THANK YOU -- FOUNDER OF A
THEME HI [inaudible]
HOLDEN NO [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THERE'S A GOOD.
ONE YEAH IT'S JUST THE CONSENT
CALENDAR YEAH.
YEAH IT'S WILL BE INVOLVED
[inaudible]
SORRY [inaudible]
OKAY.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR KERN
VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I FINAL VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
EIGHT TO ZERO FILE ITEM TWELVE
AB ELEVEN THIRTY SIX CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ONE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO FINAL VOTE
[inaudible] SIX TO TWO TWENTY
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO AB SEVENTY
NINETY SIX CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO
ZERO MATHIS.
MATHIS I FIND OF AN EIGHT TO
ZERO VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU -- HE WOULD.
HE WAS SERVICES COMMITTEE IS
ADJOURNED